this episode is brought to you by
Aeropress I love Aeropress with more
than 45
000 5 Star reviews and customers in more
than 60 countries it might be the
highest rated coffee maker on the planet
let's rewind just a bit because back in
2010 2011 I tested the entire gamut of
coffee brewing and filtering options
alongside a former Barista world
champion this was for research for the
four hour Chef that concluded with a
statement that the Aeropress was quote
Bar None my favorite Brewing method end
quote I even mentioned it and made a cup
of coffee on Late Night with Jimmy
Fallon using the Aeropress here is the
back back story remember the aerobi the
amazing ufo-like disc that you could
throw farther than a football field
Allen Adler a mechanical engineer and
Stanford University lecturer created
that then after Conquering the 1980s toy
Market he began to obsess over one thing
coffee the result was the Aeropress
which debuted into 2006 it was quickly
adopted by the specialty coffee
community and it became so popular with
the Barista community that someone in
Oslo Norway started a world Aeropress
Championship because the Aeropress
combines the best of three Brewing
methods you get a cup that is full
bodied like a French press smooth and
complex as if you were using a pour over
method and rich in flavor like espresso
best of all it's super small you can
pack it in your bag when you travel it
takes literally five seconds to clean it
is all practical no fuss and you don't
have to drink mediocre coffee at your
office or Airbnb and now they have a new
extra large version called XL that
serves two times as much coffee as the
original Aeropress pick one up at
aeropress.com Tim for a fraction of the
cost of a fancy machine that's
a-e-r-o-p-r-e-s-s.com slash Tim and my
listeners that's you guys can get 15 off
just use the link aeropress.com Tim one
more time that's aeropress.com Tim
this episode is brought to you by all
birds it is summer 2023 finally and this
is the summer to explore I'm about to do
that myself and I'm looking at the floor
in front of me literally three feet away
what do I have I have my all birds so
before you set foot out the door set
foot in the ultimate travel shoes from
all birds super comfortable and
sustainable shoes all birds are
versatile enough to go with any outfit
durable enough to wear on any terrain
and lightweight enough to make packing a
breeze plus the tree Dashers Runners
Pipers and other Albert's tree shoes are
made from insanely comfortable Breezy
eucalyptus fiber they're the only shoes
your suitcase needs I am speaking from
experience here I've been wearing all
birds for the last several months and
I've been alternating between two pairs
I'm traveling with them right now I
started with the tree runners in Marine
blue in case you're curious and now I'm
wearing the tree Dashers and the tree
Dashers are my current daily driver I
wear them for everything they're easy to
slip on easy to tie everything about
them is just easy easy simple simple I
stick with the blue hues and the Dashers
in this case are in buoyant blue the
color pops I've received a ton of
compliments but putting the color aside
the tree Dasher is an everyday running
and walking shoe that's also great for
light workouts super comfortable and
I've been testing it on long walks in
Austin I've also been testing it on the
trails and Pavement in places like New
Zealand get in vacation mode before you
even leave the house with all birds find
your perfect pair at allbirds.com today
and use code Tim that's Tim for free
socks just add them to your shopping
cart with a purchase of 48 or more
that's all birds
a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s.com and code Tim Tim
check it out
at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hand starts
shaking questions
[Music]
endoskeletons
foreign
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show it is my
pleasure as always to interview and
deconstruct world-class performers from
all different disciplines and my guest
today comes from a very strange very
mesmerizing very exciting
and certainly unique world and that is
the World of Magic Simon Coronel that's
c-o-r-o-n-e-l is legally classified as
an alien of extraordinary ability by the
United States government for his skills
as a magician and Illusionist Simon
discovered magic in 1999 as a first year
student at Melbourne University he then
spent five years working full-time in
management consulting while juggling his
secret performance career now flashing
forward he's currently a jigsaw puzzle
designer for the magic puzzle company
which is incredible in and of itself and
which also made the number one fact that
is the most backed puzzle of all time on
Kickstarter he is also a regular
performer at the Magic Castle in
Hollywood and the importance of that
will be described in this episode Simon
has appeared twice on the hit TV show
Penn and Teller fool us he has won more
than a dozen International awards for
Magic including being crowned the world
champion of magic in 2022 at fism
fism the Olympics of magic and the story
behind that is incredible which we also
dive into you can find all things Simon
at
simoncoranel.com that's
s-i-m-o-n-c-o-r-o-n-e-l.com he is one of
a kind I promise you that and you can
find more on the magic puzzle company at
magicpuzzlecompany.com so now without
further Ado please enjoy a wide-ranging
conversation with none other than Simon
Coronel
thank you
why don't you begin with explaining your
policy of radical earlyness because
I
think number one it's incredibly
strategic for Los Angeles yep but it
makes sense in a lot of other places
yeah I have noticed LA and La geography
and traffic aside one of my weaknesses
is that I am not great generally at
estimating time and planning ahead
there's almost certainly some kind of
executive function disorder going on
that I'm trying to I'm in the process
and the journey of trying to figure out
my own life but I've noticed I've
historically have been late a lot of my
life and I went you know what I don't
want to be that I don't want to be that
guy I don't want to do that to people
it's not fun and I've finally worked out
the only way I can reliably be on time
for anything is say today I know all
right I'm meeting Tim here at this
location I Google Maps for a cafe nearby
that has Wi-Fi and looks nice and I get
there an hour or two early at least an
hour ideally more often I end up there
like half an hour 20 minutes early
because of all the reasons and I just
camp out and either do work or read a
book or chill or meditate or whatever
it's easy to kill time and then by the
time I set an alarm for 10 minutes
before the thing and then just walk over
and exactly on time reliably low stress
yeah works out great I love it and it's
the only way that works is as prepping
coffee before we started recording I was
saying I've never understood
my friends who seem to want to set
personal records each time they go to
the airport for how close they can come
to missing their flight yeah because
what I'm going to be doing at the
airport and what I'm going to be doing
at home thinking about how soon I need
to go to the airport yeah are the same
so I might as well completely yeah you
are the hangout doing stuff at home or
hang out doing stuff at the airport I
also find a double benefit to that I've
really become a concert of enjoying
sitting in departure gates for an hour
or two before a flight just relax
because I'm exactly where I need to be
and how rarely are we exactly where we
need to be ahead of time with no stress
and I often find it easier to get work
done in those situations because there's
not all the distractions of my living
space totally there's not much I can do
except write or think or work or design
or whatever it is I'm going to be
working on and I'm often really
productive there
so there's another place where I feel
like you've demonstrated productivity
and that is at this bizarre amazing
enchanting location known as The Magic
Castle yeah so we met for the first time
not long ago at all was the last week
maybe at the Magic Castle can you do two
things one describe what the Magic
Castle is and perhaps also tell the
story of how you first heard of The
Magic Castle oh yeah so the Magic Castle
is it's a bizarre completely unique
place there is nothing like it on Earth
anywhere and the easiest way I think to
think of it is Imagine two very separate
unrelated things mashed together thing
number one is a nighttime Country Club
for magicians so like take a moment to
imagine that and when I say magicians
think of them more as like cinematic or
theatrical special effects designers but
live in person that's the good word
don't think Wizards don't think Harry
Potter don't think Gandalf like think
Engineers designers performers like
special effects Engineers you know who
then perform them because that's more
the mindset it's like crafted skill at
Sea and so it's this club where they can
hang out Network have drinks or dinner
together talk [__] bring guests private
club for magicians to hang out like a
professional Network that's thing number
one thing number two is a public focused
entertainment venue to take these
Illusions these magic effects and then
present those to the general public
because doing magic for magicians is at
best I don't think very useful and at
worst impossible because you know the
quote unquote magic the illusion of
impossibility happens literally in the
mind of the Observer and if you know how
it's done that illusion doesn't happen
and so you know the tree falls in the
woods and there is no sound because
there is no magic without the mystery so
you need the target audience for magic
is the general public so the Magic
Castle mashes these two unusual bizarre
things together and you get magicians
like mingling and hanging out and
chatting and like workshopping ideas and
you know gossiping or whatever it is and
then you you have the general public
like yourself coming in to experience
the results of this creativity and
workshopping and everything and it's
just it's fascinating it's a fascinating
unique bizarre place that's the real
deal it's a genuine profound part of
magic history as an artner craft and a
venue it's been around for just over 60
years it just has like 60 second or
something oh 60th anniversary was a few
years ago
and the number of stories that I was
told the number of stories that caused
me to scratch my head as I wandered
through this space with the guidance of
Jordan and others who were with us blew
my mind yeah the place is so strange it
really is and unlike anything else I've
ever seen I mean it really is like you
walked into
the equivalent of say a brilliant mind
melded with magic plus maybe some type
of psychomimetic drug yeah plus
architecture the way the whole place is
put together and has developed over time
and I remember Jordan was mentioning
over dinner that the entire Place caught
on fire or a large portion of it and it
happened to be number one on a Halloween
that was themed Inferno
number two was it on the date of Harry
Houdini's death yep yeah some people
thought it was her Houdini's ghost
others said you know it's it could be
some type of electrical short those
people are called the fire department
and it was actually a roofing accident
it was a roofing accident okay and
I was not aware for instance that the
Magic Castle had been opened seven days
a week
non-stop for the entirety of its
existence so they've not had the ability
to pause yeah to do repairs to take a
little breather
until catastrophe struck yep
incredible yeah it's one of those rare
places particularly in somewhere like La
that it's the real deal so where so many
places in LA are kind of trying to
pretend to be the thing this is the
actual thing this is the place this is
It's history and significance in the
World of Magic is infinite there's
nothing like it it's one of a kind it
really is yeah so when elonly beautiful
friend mentioned that there might be the
opportunity to go to a show
at the Magic Castle I left at the chance
and I did have to find a suit which is a
prereq cannot show zippers there are
many rules as far as dress code goes so
Hollywood Suits thank you for the 150
Joker suit that I was able to put
together it worked out and as you put it
The Eclectic mix is not Gandalf me it's
some Lord of magic from the Elven
Kingdom it's more hyper-specific at
least on I want to say the the main
floor I'm not using the right
terminology but the kind of mingling era
you have technicians and Specialists who
are the best at what they do
and one example that comes to mind and
you probably know the name I apologize
and I'm blanking on his name I have a
silhouette uh Dave spafford yes
who will look at you from the side you
stand against the wall and cut out a
perfect silhouette with his prized
scissors and you won't travel
to do this because he cannot risk the
possibility of being separated from
these incredible scissors and what this
man can do
is beyond incredible yeah in two minutes
or less for each person and I don't know
I imagine he wouldn't mind maybe you can
tell me if I need to cut this out but
she'll he worked at Disney for a really
long time and I was being told that
someone went up to him at one point I'm
masking names maybe I don't need to but
and asked him is it true that there are
all these like hidden dicks and so on
and all of these frames in these Disney
movies and he said it's absolutely true
and they said well how do you know and
he goes because I did it
yeah because back then there was no
Freeze Frame there was no stick on one
frame and hyper-examine all the details
and you could just slip it in I just
sort of space
how did you first come across the Magic
Castle this Mecca it's almost impossible
to no matter where you live in the world
if you get interested in Magic which I
did at age 18 you know it's a whole
different topic we can get to but
everyone's heard of it it's influence
extends all over the world one of the
many reasons for it is one of the things
that made the Magic Castle the Magic
Castle apart from this amazing venue and
again The Eclectic interior is back in I
don't even know the decade my magic
history sucks there was a guy called die
Vernon who a good way to think of him is
you could say he was to Magic in a way
what Einstein was to physics not the
only person by a long shot but one of
the single ones that had the biggest
single-handed influence that changed
everything that went after afterwards so
real Paradise shift and Vernon's big
contribution to Magic again I'm
oversimplifying this is
the theory of what's called naturalness
natural action that before Vernon magic
was mostly done these very sort of like
overstated bombastic gestures and he
from trying to understand like gambling
and card cheating which has to be magic
is again historically very showy and
dramatic and look at this whereas if
you're a card sheet using some of the
similar techniques of deception and
sleight of hand you have to look the
opposite you have to be completely
unassuming and unnoticeable draw no
attention to yourself and Vernon's big
innovation again oversimplifying was to
take this concept of unassuming
naturalness hiding in plain sight and
start to apply it to Magic Theory and
this just really changed everything that
went after him and to this day pretty
much every competent magician that
performs has elements of Vernon's
influence in their technique their
approach and he basically lived and hung
out at the castle for decades and he was
the main again not the only but the main
reason why magicians gradually again
practitioners of The Craft and students
of it and technicians and everything
flooded from all over the world to visit
place and then more people started to
move here and slowly Hollywood because
of the castle because of Vernon because
of the the Larson family's Vision to
like offer Vernon a really sweet deal to
live there and stay there it became this
Macker and this sort of community
gathered around it and this incubator
this pressure cooker this critical mass
of talent and ability and creativity
that still lingers to this day I'm so
fascinated by
the history of places like that
these in some respects possibly
arbitrary locations that gain a tiny
critical mass and maybe because of one
or two people
handful of people this is true of
Silicon Valley as well yeah suddenly
develop this momentum and this snowball
rolls and rolls and rolls until you have
the definitive Mecca of film yeah it's
wild yep that's the castle that's the
castle it's gone through many shifts in
its history but still it lingers it's
that reputation stays so 18 knowing
nothing about magic myself when I hear
18 I think that sounds relative to some
of the stories I have heard of the
personal histories of people who perform
magic pretty late extremely late yeah
okay much much later than average yeah
it seems like magic for a lot of folks
at least in my mind I'm like yeah it's
kind of like piano or gymnastics yeah
like you start really early yeah
18. so how did you become interested in
Magic at 18. the first thing to note
about it I think is that I think I was
lucky to get into it late we'll sort of
get to why but I was at University in
Melbourne I'd finished high school I was
interested in everything I was just in a
socially curious like sciency
engineering nerdy brand kid who just
wanted to understand the whole universe
micro all the way to macro and
everything in between underachievement
yeah small limitations oh look I mean I
don't know if I was doing a good job of
it but I was interested like that
motivation is different from results
yeah and uh and I had no idea what to do
with my life I had no real thing I was
good at I had never really excelled at
anything at that point I was sort of I
tried a whole bunch of stuff but this is
a topic I know you're into I hadn't
learned how to learn yet I hadn't
figured out how to use my own brain yet
and so I was sort of fumbling through
most things and tried a bunch of sports
and a bunch of martial arts and a bunch
of creative arts and you know got a
couple of small roles in a school play
and just nothing really clicked I wasn't
really good thing I was like adequate a
bunch and I got okay grades but again it
was school was stressful and difficult
and I didn't really find it easy and so
I sort of everyone I knew just well you
go to university next that's what you do
and to place you geographically this was
in Trenton New Jersey that's the strong
New Jersey yeah Detroit actually but
yeah close yeah yeah Melbourne Australia
Uzbekistan yes I knew it I knew it it
comes through I think in the bubble I
lived in that you know I hadn't yet
realized was a bubble because everyone
grows up what's normal to you yeah this
is what everyone does you go to
university next that's what you do and
then you get some kind of job and then
you work and retire and die like that's
it I'm like I've got a [__] I don't know
that didn't sound very exciting to me
but I didn't know any other options so I
went to University and I failed to get
into the degree I applied for which was
engineering slash law as a double major
because I don't know that's what
everyone said was good be a doctor or a
lawyer if you can I didn't have any
better ideas and I I missed out on it I
didn't quite have the grades and I got
into engineering Arts instead and so I
did a Psychology major under arts and a
software major under engineering I
started off in a computer major but I
sucked at the electrical subjects and
did okay the software subjects so I saw
the writing on the wall and shifted and
yeah blah blah blah why do you think
that was
there are two things not counting
quantum physics because no one
understands that there are two things
that I have completely failed to
understand in my life one is music one
is electronics far from the hardware
perspective yeah well from any
perspective like where what are the
electrons doing what's going on what
happens in a capacitor an inductor like
how do you design a circuit all the
stuff and I think eventually I realized
after many decades of going why can't I
understand these two damn things no
matter how much I try no matter how many
people I ask for explanations
and I think it's because for better and
worse it's a lot of both
I don't feel like I understand something
unless I completely understand it from
the ground up from the protons upwards
to The Human Experience and everything
in between
and I think the way because of how
electricity and music in their own very
different ways work
in a way no one understands them to that
level and it took me a long time to
realize that and so I was always asking
these questions about yeah but what's
actually like going on down there and I
realize like that's not the way it's
taught or thought of because I think
actually we really don't know and so I
was always frustrated so I mentioned
Jordan's name earlier Jordan gold for
people who want to check him out also
and that'll probably wrap back around
into the context of puzzles but let's
bookmark that for now totally I want to
incorporate a few things so first I
think and I don't want to put words in
your mouth but that you've described
yourself as neurodivergent would that be
fair to say something like that
neurodiverse yeah that's a new thing for
me I have spent my entire adult life
kind of hiding that and not
acknowledging that and literally in the
past few months I've kind of gone you
know what maybe it's time to start being
more open about that yeah yeah I think
it's a service to be open about it and
yeah I think there is incredible
potential and also a know thyself sort
of recommendation and funny story is all
wrapped into one in the sense that when
Jordan was explaining the many things
that make you who you are unique
idiosyncratic incredible at what you do
which we haven't we haven't yet made the
leap across from where we were where we
left off in the timeline to that but
we'll get there and he said well there's
something you need to know and I'm I'm
not doing Justice to the story but he
said let's say we were going to sit down
and make a cake
and you've probably heard this before
and you give Simon the recipe and recipe
number one is take one egg and break it
into the bowl and then there are 10 more
steps well Simon would say what is an
egg and Jordan would say you know it's
an egg everybody knows what an egg is
just one egg just that's what it is and
you said well it is really an egg and
then you would disappear for a year and
come back and you would have read all
the manuscripts the history of the egg
and the chicken and but what is a
chicken and it would have gone on and on
and on until to the finest level of
granularity an inch wide and a mile deep
you would know everything about eggs and
be like okay step number two right
and if you're aware of that predilection
and that superpower but also the risk of
doing that all the time then you can
make better choices in life which comes
back to your
phrasing of learning how to use your own
yeah so we may come back to that but
let's resume the timeline so you're
saying not particularly excellent at
anything yeah had trouble figuring out
the electronics so you shifted to
software and then what happened
shifter software and in first year like
Melbourne University is it's about a
thirty thousand at the time was a 30 000
student campus so it's a big serious
University one of the big sort of two or
three in Australia and as with many
universities I think it's similar in the
US there were lots of like student clubs
and societies yeah and during
orientation week one of the main things
they have there take you know a couple
of hundred clubs have joined us you know
that the fantasy science fiction Society
the chocolate lovers Society the beer
connoisseur Society the Taekwondo club
like it's everything you can imagine and
a lot more that you some of them are
stupid ridiculous ones some of them are
very serious special interest ones and I
was just wandering around trying to join
stuff to you know try and get out of my
shell and explore a bit and take
advantage of being on a University
campus and there was a table for the
Melbourne University magician society
and I'd had like a magic kit when I was
10 but it had as much effect on me as it
did almost 10 year olds nothing I had no
ability it was confusing I gave up after
two days and but you know magic was one
of the many things I was interested in
like everything you know I wanted to
learn how everything worked in the world
again wasn't doing a great job of it and
they sang magic club what do you guys do
and they said well you know magic like
card tricks and stuff I'm like oh I
can't do any of that I tried but I
sucked so gave up as you do and they
said well if you join we teach you that
we've got a beginner's course and I was
like ah I don't know I mean I don't I'm
not very dexterous and I was like why
not give it a shot and I remember they
had really cool membership cards which I
thought was cool that kind of tipped me
over the edge and so I just kind of
joined and then I forgot that I joined
for the next month because I had other
things going on it was very busy and
then Tina the club secretary called me
up on my parents landline because this
is pre I didn't own my Nokia 3310 yet at
this point the story I said hey we've
got you downstairs having signed up but
not turned up do you still want to come
I was like oh yeah magic club right
that's right oh yeah when do you meet
again Wednesday is 1pm great
and then Wednesday 1 pm rocked around
and I was like 1pm I was supposed to be
somewhere I hadn't discovered radical
illness yet I'm like I think oh crap
magic club that's right oh God where is
it again damn so I turned off about 15
minutes late just in time to see someone
this guy Brian who was one of the
special guest sort of teachers
explaining this trick and he was
basically going okay now via the blah
blah blah technique at jargon term I
didn't know at the time you know their
card is the King of Clubs and you could
just say that or you could use the blah
blah technique that we talked about last
week and then he took a seven of
diamonds waved it on the table and it
changed like right
10 inches in front of me into a King of
Clubs and this was the most incredible
thing I'd ever seen in my entire life it
was just like reality broke down in
front of me everything I knew about life
and physics what the it was just this
Transcendent consuming moment and I sort
of made semi-incoherent noises of like
wait what the heck what huh what is that
and Brian not realizing I hadn't been
turning up for them so far
quote unquote reminded me oh the blah
blah technique like this from last week
where you do this and this and so in
seconds I went from being profoundly
transcendently amazed to seeing how it
was done and it was like whose code is
it uh give me a lever long enough and a
place to stand a comedians yeah it felt
like that it was this Revelation that
from this not easy but simple technique
you could do the most profoundly
transcendently amazing thing I'd ever
seen in my life and the implication of
the leverage of that was just
extraordinary it's like discovering that
you can sort of poke a table and power
the entire city with the energy of that
poke it was just I was so fascinated and
just started going to that club every
week and just became completely
intrigued by what is this art and craft
and what the hell and the motivation was
purely understanding it was just
knowledge seeking I just want to
understand this thing I'd seen yeah if
you see something amazing intrinsically
I want to understand it and learn more
about it so that's where you got your
first hit of magic oh yeah oh it's a
powerful drug
all right so you get that hit and the
way I want to play this is I'd love to
flash way forward and then we're gonna
fill in some gaps along the way I like
it I can see the screenplay now exactly
let's go writing the screenplay in my
head love it as we go
I've already bought your life right so I
hope you don't mind
I wasn't doing anything yeah I wasn't
doing anything good with them
all right the name of the show that I
saw at the Magic Castle what is it
glitches in reality glitches in reality
all right so glitches in reality setting
the stage I've never heard your name
before
but Elon says trust me I'm not sure if
we can get space but if we can get a c
you need to come and I take that very
seriously he's an enthusiastic guy but
he's not a bullshitter
and
I wanted to move anything and everything
necessary to come to the show just based
on pure Faith yep
landed the show and Jordan was kind
enough to also get a spot for a friend
of mine who had never been to a magic
show which would be relevant shortly
rule number one unless you only ever
want to go downhill do not go to Simon's
show first as your only magic show you
should just quit while you're ahead in
that case and we go in my favorite magic
not that I have much vocabulary much
experience but as a spectator
as an awe Seeker but also a truth Seeker
maybe we'll come back to that at some
point I love anything that is reasonably
close up just like the car changing in
front of you 10 inches from your face
lately and by far the best magic show
I've ever seen so I want to say that
probably number one and we can parse out
why that is the case but the combination
of wonder
explanation surprise and also
for me
your ability to Showcase almost a
decathlon of magic in terms of to my
muggle mind a wide breadth of different
skills that makes any sense completely
and when you towards the end
began to set up and tell the story
of
fism and we're going to come back to
that Elon almost ejaculated his pants I
don't know how else to put it and I
don't want to make too strong a case but
I thought he was either having a seizure
or ejaculating I wasn't sure maybe both
he was so excited because you guys are
friends and he had told me that
after the World Championships which
we'll get to in a moment he thought you
may never perform
this trick and we'll get to what this
trick is ever again
and it was one of the most spectacular
mind-bending things I've ever seen
in my life thanks you're welcome could
you please tell the story
of the World Championships oh boy and I
know there are a million ways this can
be told and guess what they're all good
yeah so how many hours have you got we
have all the time
I'm still working out how to tell this
story because again there are so many
ways it can be told let's start with a
short version and then you can unpack
request unpacking any bits you think are
relevant and maybe do you mind if I make
this sort of participatory journalism
sure and I'll give people just a
snapshot from the the screenplay
absolutely I defer to your expertise all
right the sort of in media arrests we
start in the middle of the action
and
so to set the stage pun intended
you can correct me on some of the
particulars but
you're being judged by your peers yeah
at this event they are watching magic
all day long you are close to the end
you perform your trick
and then
invite people up to inspect your work if
they don't believe it's real
and it effectively shuts down the venue
because there is a rush of 2 000 plus
people to the stage to inspect this yeah
to the extent that it becomes a problem
for the organizers it becomes a safety
risk
it's just the ultimate magical mic drop
no one had ever seen anything like it
yeah okay now you can start wherever the
only small correction I'd make to that I
mean it wasn't quite two thousand people
it was a lot it was hundreds of hundreds
of hundreds of people but the thing that
made it even more powerful for me
personally was that I didn't actually
invite them up what happened was I had
one person on stage who gets given the
thing that is created and they then go
back to their seat I'm like thank you
very much you know you get to keep that
that now gets to linger in the world and
I just went cool thanks bye and just
left the stage I'm like thank God that's
over oh my God that was so stressful we
did it we got there and then I was just
backstage decompressing going oh God
thing oh man so glad that's over finally
I can relax over months I've been
looking forward to this moment where I
could finally stop stressing then a
friend comes backstage and goes you
should come look at this I'm like what
let's just come look and I walk out and
I see that this mob has gathered like
spontaneously it wasn't even invited I
didn't expect this would happen yeah I'm
just like oh my God holy yeah
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
LinkedIn jobs these days every new
potential hire can feel like a high
stakes gamble for your small business so
you want to be 100 certain that you have
access to the most qualified candidates
that's why you should check out LinkedIn
jobs LinkedIn jobs helps you find the
right people for your team faster and
for free at your job and the purple
hashtag hiring frame to your LinkedIn
profile to spread the word that you're
hiring simple tools like screening
questions make it easy to focus on
candidates with just the right skills
and experience so you can quickly
prioritize who you'd like to interview
and hire it's why small businesses rate
LinkedIn jobs number one and delivering
quality hires versus leading competitors
LinkedIn jobs helps you find the
qualified candidates you want to talk to
faster so post your job for free at
linkedin.com Tim that's linkedin.com Tim
to post your job for free terms and
conditions apply
so as a kid
I was not particularly happy I was not
having a great time growing up nothing
super horrifying but I just didn't fit
in again I now know neurodivergent that
tends to not be a good time if you don't
know that and you're a kid in a normal
sort of area and I realized I was always
interested I figured this out in
hindsight this was looking back I saw
the pattern I was interested in stuff
that involved kind of breaking out of
reality like ESP and aliens and the
X-Files and space exploration and
quantum physics and science fiction and
just ways that I life felt just so
mundane and uninspiring and gray and
dreary and just ugh and all those things
for different reasons weren't accessible
to me Australia didn't have a space
program so I couldn't be an astronaut
quantum physics was real but too hard
hypnosis was real but not that
interesting to me
aliens don't seem to be real sadly as
far as I can tell who knows there was
just no way I wanted out of reality I
want life to be more extraordinary and
so when I saw this magic club and I saw
this card trick at age 18 it was the
first time
in my life that
it felt like again there was like a
crack in reality that I could sort of
see something brighter and more
extraordinary through and again I only
realized it's like a decade later
looking back and trying to make sense of
the path it only becomes clear in
hindsight so it makes sense now I got so
captivated by Magic it was the first
time I could kind of engage with that
with something more extraordinary and
that that altered state of consciousness
that was profound
and so I became obsessed but again I
wasn't particularly gifted at it there
was no apparent natural talent but I
loved it so much that I kept going
despite the absence of natural talent
and as we know that's what tends to make
a difference is if you love it enough to
stick with it and enjoy the process with
no thought as to the destination which
will become a theme as well I think
and so then fast forward a bunch of
years I'm working full time at a
graduate job which I don't really like
but it's good experience and some of the
people there were great and I'm glad I
did it but I didn't really fit in it was
the job I worked for ROM Accenture big
business consulting company and again I
met some great people there shout out to
Grant and Thomas and
Jackie and everybody else but it wasn't
really my thing it didn't play to my
strengths it played to a lot of my
weaknesses which I didn't really
understand at the time and the magic was
continuing to grow in the background it
was a real passion but there wasn't
really a sense I could ever do that
professionally I didn't see much of a
market for it where I lived and I
started to sort of win little
competitions locally which was amazing
this was the first time I displayed any
sort of noteworthy skill at anything
which was kind of addictive it's a good
feeling we want to feel significant and
competent at things and I hadn't mostly
in my life so how did you decide to
participate in your first competition it
was a thing a guy called Nigel
McCullough in Melbourne a magician ran a
little one-day Magic Convention a get
together just to have a bunch of
workshops and shows called Melbourne's
magic Malaki in 2001 and it had this
close-up magic competition and at the
time I can't remember why I think I'd
like read something or just this idea
that it's worth trying things even if
they fail because you gained experience
from it and again at the time this was a
new idea to me because I was young and
you everything I went yeah you know what
why not you know step into the arena you
know try a thing there was a zero
percent chance in my mind that I had a
shot at it and I ended up winning it
partly because again the thing with
competitions it's often who turns up on
the day for sure and also the theme that
I've often not really realized
how what I'm doing will be experienced
or perceived by others again
neurodivergency well we talked about
this I don't want to take care of track
so keep your place but even before we
started I was asking journalism exactly
I was asking you if you had any Greatest
Hits stories or stories that were really
well received by the audience and I'm
paraphrasing it but that's not a
superpower that I have in terms of
identifying what will be interesting to
other people so that's why I've
frequently been surprised by what people
haven't haven't found resonant so I
enter and I unexpectedly went and I go
holy [__] very unexpected and so that
was the first sort of sense I got that
maybe maybe I'm kind of onto something
here maybe I've got something I'm doing
that's working that's kind of exciting
so I kept starting to enter all the
competitions and also I learned from it
it's great to have a deadline it's great
to have a challenging slightly healthy
stressful thing to work towards so I
kept sort of doing that I found
competitions useful as a way to grow and
I kept winning little ones locally which
was really gratifying and then fast
forward a few years of this and still
working full-time at the job doing magic
on the side on weekends often when
exhausted from 12 hour days at a big
corporate job and then going out to like
open mics to grind in material and try
and get experience and workshop things
and just burning the candle just like
holding the candle in the fire with
tongs not even more on both ends I was
just really burning out but I was so
excited it needed to make a living and
still chase this passion again with no
thought that it was going to be a
profession or anything at this point it
was just like I just loved it
intrinsically it was fascinating and
then 2009 so the Magic World
Championships the sing fism which stands
for something in French that we can get
into or not it's basically a way to
think of it is like imagine like the UN
of magic clubs and again magic club's
professional organizations for
technicians designers who try to create
the illusions of impossibility right
that's the way to think of magic special
effects design but live and in some ways
more powerful and so organizations where
these people get together and workshop
and talk and exchange ideas
some of those then affiliate with fizzm
which is French for International
Federation of magic societies that began
in like the 50s as a way to kind of like
try to unite like to make some
International collaboration which is a
really healthy nice thing and it's like
any organization there's politics and
there's a bunch of [__] but mostly
it's a really good thing overall
and the main thing they run is every
three years they have a big competition
that is kind of the de facto Magic World
Championships as a way to kind of I
think of it as to paraphrase Rick and
Morty every three years fizm says to the
world of magic show us what you got
right and all the magic shows what it's
got and it's always got something cool
and also a lot of stuff that sucks and
everything in between
and in 2009 it was going to be in China
for the first time ever it's mostly been
in Europe throughout its history it's
always in a different city around the
world and I ended up with the
opportunity to be the only Australian
entrant because clubs get given entry
slots pro-rated based on membership and
Australia has a very small population
and so again getting those critical
masses is very hard in Australia and
it's one of the reasons I eventually
came to the US to seek more people and
more inspiration there are plenty of
really cool people there but again the
critical mass just isn't there as much
and I went oh my God the prospects to
who gets the chance to represent their
country at the World Championships of
anything particularly a kid who didn't
really you know have much he felt he was
talented at this was extraordinary and
terrifying and all the things and so I
did it and much like kind of Rocky I
just wanted to compete and not embarrass
myself or my country that was the goal
just to compete at a world stage was
already more than I'd ever imagined
and I ended up worked for over a year on
preparing the routine and getting ready
for the competition and ended up tying
for third prize in the closet magic
category which was so far beyond what
I'd imagined I think about that that
thing that the the bronze medalist is
often happier than the silver medalist
totals the silver medals missed out on
gold the bronze medalist missed out on
having nothing you know who's even
happier than the bronze medalist who's
the person who tied for bronze because
maybe fourth place was a long way below
you but when you tie for third you are a
hairs breath from nothing you just
squeaked into something and I was
ecstatic and it was amazing and uh very
quickly I realized that I was like oh my
god I've made it this is incredible and
then it did nothing for my career or
life in any way whatsoever so that
Band-Aid got ripped off pretty quickly
which was probably healthy nice
there was the moment where the Chinese
media came up and I was there with a
friend who'd won second prize in his
category and we were going oh my God
this is amazing the Chinese media come
up and go you are you are Prize winners
am I like yeah thinking yes this is
awesome we're going to be famous now and
they go oh what did you win I got I tied
for third in close-up magic and Charlie
here came second in parlor magic and
they went uh not first I'm like oh no
but like and then they just oh sorry and
left
it's like I don't even think we got 15
minutes of Glory before just that the
cold water was dumped on us
which is the shortest route from
exuberance to just oh Charlie Brown walk
away from the room
so that happened that happened then in
2012 three years later I enter again
it's now in the UK this time
and the very short version of that very
long story is I prepare a different
routine again for over a year and I find
out about two weeks before the
competition that a big chunk of what I'm
planning to do isn't going to work
now normally what you would do is pull
out of the competition at that point or
try and find something else to replace
it and come up with something I possibly
naively stupidly chose the latter
turns out I'm not a quitter once I once
we're doing it we're doing it and it was
insane I am still kind of astonished you
could call it legal Insanity that went
for it worked with an amazing group of
people friends shout out to Dave and Yao
and YC and everybody in Melbourne who
helped with that and all the names I'm
now forgetting in the moment and somehow
got something adequate over the line and
it ended up winning the award for most
original close-up act not best closer
back but most original which isn't
necessarily the same and I think it was
because in that insane pressure cooker
of having to come up with something I
came up with something so bizarre and
unusual
out of just sheer Brute Force necessity
of what can we do with what's available
there wasn't any time to develop any
sort of good polished methods we had to
just use some bizarre stuff and just
decide you know what I don't even know
if this is going to work but let's try
it and miraculously it did work barely
like I still watch the video of that and
just oh God the amount of things that
almost went wrong but failed to is still
insane somehow it got across the line
and got this originality award which
again I hadn't expected hadn't been
aiming for originality I just been
aiming to not [__] the bed in front of 2
000 people that was a hundred percent of
my goal at that point of like oh God
sometimes close bedfellas pun intended
right
exactly there's still this amazing photo
somewhere of me on stage in 2012
accepting this award with this
completely bemused expression on my face
I bet later but just surprised by the
last thing I saw coming and so that
happened and the idea that I threw
together at the last minute that came to
me at like 4 a.m while stressed out and
vaguely panicked was I'd always been
obsessed with this idea of can you take
this fleeting Transcendent instant of
Wonder and somehow preserve it into
something physical and tangible that
lengthens that moment lets you sit in
that space longer because I love that
space that space is powerful and
life-changing and the idea was what if
you didn't act where you create one of
these things live because these things
exist but you see the finished result
but not the process or if you could
create the illusion of it being created
instantly so a piece of the ACT then
lingers beyond the end of it into the
world and that was the idea and in 2012
I did this first kind of very rough
janky thrown together seed of the pants
version of it that was not good but
worked and I love the idea and I also
then gave up on Magic competitions
because they're great they serve a
purpose but at the time I was trying to
have a career I now quit my full-time
job to go full magic which I don't
necessarily recommend but has been going
okay we'll come back we'll come to that
and I was trying to make a career I was
trying to find a way to make a living
which is often the opposite of Art and
creativity sadly not always but
sometimes and this idea of this like
creating the impossible object in the
ACT I didn't see any commercial
potential to it it was so high touch so
much setup played so small and I'm like
I love this but I need to shelve this
and work on something else but it nagged
me it ate away at me and putting effort
into magic competitions I wasn't seeing
any career pay off to that at the time
so I went you know what I've got to
focus on actual getting gigs earning
money
show the competitions and the creative
projects and for 10 years that stayed
that way until in 2019 again this still
this is the short version it's highly
highly abbreviated yeah this is the
incredibly abbreviated story
I started ended up in jigsaw puzzle
design separate story we'll get to and
left magic as a profession which was
really liberating because I love magic I
love it as an art it's a horrible
business to be in like most of the Arts
The Comedians know the jugglers know all
the variety entertainers know the actors
know most the musicians know it's rough
it's brutal it's hard and a lot of my
weaknesses were very
relevant my strengths didn't play well
my weaknesses were very hindering and I
found it really hard to build a career
and so when the prospect of getting a
creative product design came up work on
a thing with a good team of people put
it into the world and have it scale
passively in the background not
completely passively it was amazing and
you don't have to turn up to be earning
the money and also being a magician's
like being unemployed every gig is often
a once-off so you're constantly having
to hustle and hustle for the next gig
and I'm not great at that so quit Magic
full time my great it's now a hobby ah
glorious I can just do the bits I'm
excited by I'm passionate by
and then the pandemic happened and all
kinds of crazy stuff happened and it was
a weird time for everybody and during
that time the 2022 Magic Championships
was coming up
and I just went great this is awesome
I'm a hobbyist amateur magician now I
can just go and hang out it doesn't
matter there's no stress and then I
realized that I know myself now I'm
going to enjoy it more if I'm I'll
always pick creating over consuming
if Governor Choice it's more rewarding
gotta get that you know that little
garnish of trauma right that little yeah
I really feel it it's like the spicy
chili or the bit of coffee like oh if
you feel it you know you're alive
and I thought well I could do maybe get
book to do a show there's all kinds of
events and then I remembered that 2012
routine that kind of very janky version
of a really beautiful idea that I'd
loved
and worked on I went you know and I'd
been thinking about that ever since in
weak moments I would sort of work on
bits of a version or idea on how to fix
it and improve it and they go no no I
shouldn't be working on this I should be
working on my career and then a year
later I'd be like ah I think I have
another idea on how to solve this
problem and I kept trying to fight and
it kept not being solvable it was one of
these impossible problems and then in
that lockdown hiding out in the midwest
in 2021 away from everything and all the
insanity and the chaos and I was like I
think I finally have the last piece of
it this is not quite the right analogy
but having the idea and actually
actualizing it executing it as our buddy
Derek silver says ideas and execution is
so different and I was like I think I
can do this but
it's going to take months of work to
even test it to find out and the way the
Magic Championships works is the year
before they have Regional Continental
qualifiers they're the North American
the South American the Asian the
European the African and the oceanian
like mini championships the North
American championships was coming up in
about six months and I went you know
what I need a deadline to make my brain
hyper Focus I'll enter that it'll be
small this was still during lockdown it
was post vaccines but still in lockdowns
it won't be very well attended
if I can't get this idea together and it
shits the bed
it'll only shoot the bed in front of a
small relatively small audience and if
it doesn't [__] the bed I'll know all
right I've got something and I have a
year to really work on it to make it
good I went great you know low stress
just high enough stress to do it and so
I spent the next six months in crunch
mode going okay let's take a swing at
this let's see if I can bring this thing
to life and I work like a maniac I go
into full Workshop rehearsal testing
Theory mode and I go to the North
American championships again just to
kind of see if this thing's got legs or
not I don't really know yet I don't know
what I've got or not and I win the whole
thing I become the North American closer
magic champion and once again I'm
shocked I'm completely surprised I did
not see this coming and I go oh
I guess it does have legs oh [__] okay
all right we got something here and then
how much do you know about when a
caterpillar turns into a butterfly what
happens inside the Chrysalis I'm gonna
go with very little okay just so I don't
get Cuts is the Emperor with no clothes
I also am not a biologist was it an
entomological biologist this is one of
the most amazing things I've learned
about the natural world you would think
that the caterpillar maybe changes shape
a bit then you know Sprouts wings and
now it's a butterfly turns out the
caterpillar basically liquefies into
primordial sludge with small chunks of
neural matter still in there and then
from that primordial soup the butterfly
then just basically grows into its full
form which is astounding and it retains
memories and experience through this
process and they've done you know scans
of this to see that this is what happens
which
is one of the most again magical in the
sense of seems impossible
turns to sludge and then reforms into a
completely different organism and I
realized in the months I was working
before the real Championship that at the
North American championships I felt like
I had I'd won the prize for like best
caterpillar in show I'm like this
thing's great great caterpillar oh my
God what a caterpillar damn but I had
this hunch that I think this thing could
fly I think this thing might be able to
grow wings like maybe
and that meant it had to turn into
sludge and there's a lot of people who
can relate to that creativity and so for
the next like eight months
I went to the Magic Castle because one
of the best things about that place is
it has these areas where magician
members can go and do little impromptu
shows for you know whichever public
members are around it's hard to find
open mics you need places to test stuff
you only get good by doing and
experiencing and that's hard to find for
most variety Arts magic included and
it's one of the reasons I live near the
place and I went there on quiet nights
because
to get the routine to this better place
I had to kind of break it and test out
these things that you can only test them
in front of people you need an
observer's mind is where the magic
happens
and it wasn't good and it was awkward it
was uncomfortable and I hated it and I
would wait till there were just like
three people rather than Gathering a big
crowd to get good energy I'd be like ah
no I don't want anyone to see it sucking
while it's in this crappy phase and just
went there night after night just again
and again it was brutal and it was
unpleasant but
slowly wove it together and started to
find a way to get the improvements so
question yeah just on that process
because I saw the room yeah where you
did a lot of that practice Yeah tiny
little room and I saw the performance
when things worked yeah okay yeah so
when you're workshopping this rough
material and it makes me think of a long
time ago when I was in the Bay Area I
was actually a judge for an amateur
comedy competition yeah but there were a
couple of pros and they would bring
their notebooks up on stage and
something would just die on the vine
wouldn't get any responsibility like
okay we're gonna cut that one and then
they'd pull up in their notebook and on
stage they would make their notes and
yep I loved seeing the under the hood
process
when you were performing for say three
people yeah and it sucks to use your
word
does that mean it works but it's not
pretty does that mean it just completely
falls apart and does not work it doesn't
produce the illusion and what do you say
or do when people have come to be
entertained and it doesn't work the
answer is sort of all of the above there
are so many different failure modes
which again is sort of the engineering
mindset the different ways it can fail
with this particular thing I was working
on in in this story there was one
particular thing I needed to accomplish
secretly without anyone seeing it was
submission impossible type [__] you know
your mission should you choose to accept
it is you know the parameters should
have been impossible and I was trying to
find a way to make this work and I had a
hunch there might be a way but it relied
on sort of like nuanced body language
based misdirection and like how human
perception actually works and how to
kind of slip that through the cracks in
ways that were really hard to theorize
and you have to kind of feel it and so I
would prefix it knowing that there was a
solid chance of it failing by going hi
I'm testing on something new if it works
it'll be amazing if it doesn't work
it'll be hilarious
you know that set expectations it
informed consent they know what they're
getting into and it's a weird place
because I don't know which one of those
it's going to be and if it works they
are going to see something astounding
and then they're going to see me go was
that any good like was that it was just
such a jarring experience for them to
see me just break reality and they go uh
was that was that any good did you did
you see the thing that I hoped you
didn't see like what the hell like it
just but then if they did see the thing
they'd be like I mean yeah because I'm
I'm letting them know I want their
feedback and it's often hard to get
people to give you that feedback because
often they mistakenly think that being
polite is better is helpful they don't
hurt your feelings I know it's the
opposite I like hurt me punch me in the
face like let's go give me the pain I
need to know I want the painful truth of
the Beautiful Lie this is what we need
right now and usually you can see it on
their faces even if they're trying to
hide you can sort of see that their eyes
flicker to where the thing happened I'm
like damn it ah all right well lesson
learned back the drawing board let's try
it again tomorrow and if it does work
they just you see the Wonder and so it's
great we got it that time now let's try
and make sure that happens every time
with an error margin
so you're putting in the Reps putting in
the Reps just grinding through the Reps
for weeks and months and it gets down to
the point where I've sort of got two
approaches kind of figured out there's
two paths to making this thing work and
they each have different pros and cons
and I can't really decide between them
one is the slightly like riskier one
that looks better but has a different
problem again a classic engineering
situation you just have to decide
between the trade-offs
and with now it's just a few weeks away
and I go all right we're going to pick
one and focus on and I picked the safer
one that is less amazing but like more
reliable
so we go to the competition and it's a
six day event and it's the competition
but also shows and workshops and panel
discussions and events and all kinds of
cool it's a whole big beautiful
celebration Festival yeah exactly and
the competition's the main thing and
annoyingly uh my friends shoot and I so
shoot uh is a really good magician
friend who was also competing in a
different category and we'd been
training each other really like
supporting each other on the journey and
trying to do our thing and we're both on
the final day which is annoying because
what I want to do is rip off the
Band-Aid early and then enjoy the
festival but instead I have to make sure
I get to sleep and make sure I stay
healthy and so I can't go too hard
because I spent like a year and a half
working towards this in a way I spent 10
years working towards this I don't care
if I win I'm just there to do the thing
and to see if we can close this
narrative Arc because it'll be more
engaging because the fact it was exactly
10 years felt just too perfect to let
that go it's such a beautiful plot Arc
I'm like I want to see if this thing can
fly and if it can't that's okay because
at least I'll know at least I tried the
thing
and shoots in a similar place he's just
entering because it's been a pandemic we
haven't been able to do this for so many
years he wants to be part of it
so it's the final day actually it's not
yet because two days before the final
day I'm lying awake shoot and I sharing
a hotel room and I have insomnia which
doesn't happen to me much and I'm lying
away because adrenaline and time zone
and just it's not surprising I'm lying
awake staring at the ceiling going God
damn it get to sleep
and then suddenly it's one of those
moves where my eyes widen and I just
suddenly see the Matrix and I'm like
holy [__]
I suddenly think I've seen a way to
combine these two approaches and get the
best bits of both two days two days
before yeah and this always happens to
me this every day it's a running joke
with friends in Melbourne who know the
Muse only visits 48 to 36 hours for the
day 48 hours before a go time every damn
time that's when the Muse turns up I
playfully anthropomorphize my muse I
think of her as like I'm like arguing
with her going could you one time turn
up three weeks out and she's like no and
I'm like oh you know what terribly sorry
appreciate you please don't stop turning
up yep no all right that's I guess
that's what it's gonna be looks like
that's the schedule yep all right thank
you appreciate you please don't don't
leave so she turns up at 4am two days
before and just punches me in the face
with this idea and I'm like oh my God
hang on and
shoot is asleep in the he's a pretty
sound sleeper we've traveled together a
lot now for many gigs and I realize hang
on I think often you need to think with
your body I find you need to sort of
work through it and block through it so
I get up very quietly try not to wake
him up and in the Darkness
is like dim light of the Moon through
you know slit in the window I sort of
work through this idea thinking am I
insane will this work
and I kind of think I think this might
have legs but I don't know if I'm just
sleep deprived and delusional so I write
down a bunch of notes on It For My
Future Self in the morning to go like in
case I forget and then I don't get to
sleep I'm just lying there my mind's
racing I'm like I think hang on maybe is
this gonna work and finally shoot wakes
up what the [__] are you doing
he's used to it he's not surprised the
amount of weird [__] we've seen each
other doing for magic over the years
like it's all so much Stranger Than
Fiction he just looks at me as like
uh-huh I go okay so full disclosure I
haven't slept so I might be a little
manic what do you think of this idea and
shoot is legendary for being a friendly
beautiful human but very sort of blunt
with his feedback and his opinion he
breaks a lot of people's Spirits
unintentionally because he's just the
dream destroyer exactly very very sort
of yeah like a younger Mr Miyagi like I
don't know and
I go okay here's the idea we all know
each everything about each other's acts
at this point I'm going because so this
version this version I think if I do
this and do this and then that and that
gives us the best bit of this but
without the drawback of this because
this angle and this perceptual focal
Direction this here and there's this
what do you think is this something is
it got legs and he looks at me and
thinks and goes
I can't say no
which from him which is like April High
Praise he's like yeah cause no maybe
like ah but you know this wouldn't work
so I'm like oh [__] okay and then I ran
it by Jordan as well later on like again
haven't slept might be a little manic
you know I'm learning how to you know
interact and filter properly
and he's like yeah I think maybe and I'm
like all right
so then I spend the next day and a half
because that's all I've got blocking
through this new version it's not a
massive when you say blocking what do
you mean just blocking in the theatrical
sense as in kind of walking through it
physically like going through the whole
motions because a lot of magic again the
Vernon theory of naturalness is about
looking like your body has no tension
where there is actually a lot of
tensional Vice Versa or faking tension
where there is none and you kind of need
to in the same way that a special
effects designer is lying with their CGI
lying for the benefit of the audience
lying for to create something beautiful
you have to sort of lie with your whole
body sure in a really a way that's
really takes a long time to kind of get
intuitive and is one of the hardest
things about learning magic at a high
level you know I just realized also
something about you which tell me if
this is an accurate perception and that
is you may not be able to
put yourself in the mines or the shoes
of say certain listeners of stories but
you would have to be quite good at
putting yourself behind the eyes
at the very least absolutely yeah of
your Spectators of your marks yeah
because the angles matter yeah
absolutely and the knowledge and the
preconceptions and the assumptions and
the just the ways people perceive
reality around them absolutely is
literally the medium with which you know
the magician slash Illusionist works and
the common misconceptions you know the
hands or the cards or the coins or the
whatever but no I mean those are the
tools but you are sculpting the
perceptions of an observer into a
beautiful amazing shape you need to be
present to that that is the sculpture
that you are crafting and the thing
where I find that's different about
things like what stories would be
interesting is perception of physical
reality is a much more Universal
consistent thing than people's creative
preferences or personal preferences or
wants or needs or desires or interests
that is hugely variable between people
and I think in any sort of at least for
me the the neurodivergencies are more
about those things are more Divergent
what I like what I'm interested it in
what I want to hear about what I don't
whereas perception of physical objects
perceptual faculties for survival that
have evolved over time exactly that's
pretty much the same for everyone pretty
consistent not everybody but all we are
way higher percentage so you're 48 Hours
roughly out you're not sleeping come on
Simon for [__] sake get to sleep Muse
is like
music's just punched on your face with
amazing things and I'm like thank you I
think so now you you think you have
something I think I've got something
how do you balance maybe that's not even
the word to use
prepping with something new before game
time with trying to get some sleep yeah
I definitely try to get sleep sleep is
important I don't really have a process
I just sort of feel it and I get it to a
point where I think it's good enough I
have a bit of a background in improv
acting which is one of the best things I
ever studied in my life and being okay
with just kind of again the friends from
Melbourne who are listening shout out to
dominion and everybody else know that
I'm inevitably like hours before a show
building something new to try in it I
think a lot about this idea of the two
thresholds of imagine that you
oversimplify how good is a performance
into a single axis which is ridiculously
oversimplified but say you know at the
bottom is the worst thing you've ever
seen this is like the y-axis on a graph
exactly and the top is the best thing
you've ever seen in your life again
however simplification but for the sake
of argument it's uh that George box
quote all conceptual models are wrong
but some are useful and this is wrong
but useful and I often think about what
we're trying to go upwards we're trying
to get high on the scale you want to be
that show was really good some people
think it was the best thing they've ever
seen some people think it's really good
and there's an infinite number of lines
you could draw on that graph and the two
that I think about the most is
somewhere very high up is people in the
audience are thinking that is one of the
best things I've ever seen ever in my
life across all categories of experience
holy [__] that's always where I'm aiming
at I don't think I hit it I think most
people never hit it maybe I'll hit it
one day before I die that would be
amazing maybe I won't that's okay but
I'm aiming at that I think about the
Bruce Lee quote the aim the punch two
inches beyond the intended point of
impact aiming at the line I don't need
to hit it to feel happy but then way
lower is the line above which not one
person the audience felt like they
wasted their time or their money I'm
willing to take risks down to that line
but not below it if I go below that line
then I'll beat myself up then I have a
karmic debt to repay to the world but
above that line my conscience is clean
my karma is clear and I'm willing to
take risks to explore and experiment
down to that line and this is a bit
different because the world damn
championships so the minimum Line's a
bit higher and so it's more I get at the
line where I'm like I'm confident that
this is going to do extremely likely to
work to the highest level you can never
be certain but I'm confident I've got
this and it'll work and at that point I
chill and get some sleep and try and
relax okay
and then and that's the competition uh
and then I'm up and it's terrifying and
I'm ready one of my favorite little
tangent about again a thousand stories
we could tell because why is it actually
worth doing anything what do we do
before we die what makes you happy what
makes you what do you find fulfilling
one of the things back in 2012 that made
that
performance I did so insane as a weird
method is one of my best friends in
Melbourne Dave
helped out by and this is massive
spoiler first time it's revealed hiding
under the table during the ACT this is
not a method this is not something
magicians do this is Ridiculousness
absurd this was a desperation move of
just a Brute Force approach heinously
inelegance and basically like
constructing things during the ACT to
make this thing possible which was such
a ridiculous thing to do as a method but
I'm like we don't have time to come up
with something better we're just going
The Brute Force thing under the table
you go yep Dave and Dave's like I got
this and that's again there's a group of
friends there again like Dave and
dominion and YC and yeah that many of us
have done this for each other what do
you need we're on it Jason Bourne a
non-violent Jason Bourne kind of
mentality like what needs to be done
we'll get it done I've hidden under the
table for friends in various other
bizarre situations to build [__] which
is wonderful it's like the behind the
scenes and so it became a running joke
that Simon's magic is done by Dave being
under the table
not the case this is not how magic is
done but it became a running joke and so
again that was 10 years ago now for this
one I've realized for six months I've
got a bit that I want to do I've got a
joke I want to make in homage to these
wonderful friends and these beautiful
people have helped along the way and in
this act it doesn't use a table it uses
this tiny little side stand that's part
of that's one of the problems with the
2012 one it was cumbersome it was bulky
it was inefficient inelegant this one's
very simple and clear and minimalist
and on this little side stand that I'm
putting the very few props I have that
I've always been a minimalist in my
tastes I make a little video
10 minutes before I go on stage for the
world championships and to me that's
what makes this funny that's what makes
this good that it's there in the arena
and I record a little video of the table
going all right guys going on stage in
10 minutes well championships just
pre-show check I opened my little box
I'm like yep all the props are there is
everyone where they need to be and I pan
down and look under the table and
there's a photo of Dave take on the
table everyone's in place we've got
everyone need to be all right we're
ready and I send that to the group chat
and like that was the thing I really
wanted to do like stuff like that that's
the actual beauty of it so on the game
day yeah I'm just wondering because
you're on the last day no last day okay
so I have had the fortunate opposite
experience the only time that I spoke on
the Ted main stage I was in the opening
session and I was so grateful because it
was a lot of pressure and stress on one
hand but then I could enjoy the rest of
the event completely and I knew that I
would otherwise just be mentally
rehearsing my own act the entire time so
walk us through game day okay and what
it's like leading up to it also so game
day well and also before game day
because you're so right like exactly
what you described as what's way better
and instead I'm watching all the
competitions with friends and it's also
a great celebration of magic and
amazement but we're watching going again
so much of how it goes is who's there is
there someone way better than you is no
who's turning up from all you know who
are the belgians bringing who are the
Italians bringing you know who's here
from South Korea you know what what is
the world going to deliver that might be
amazing and and again the goal isn't to
win but still you can't help but kind of
want to maybe imagine oh no but then you
don't imagine that's that's setting
yourself up for disappointment you don't
want to think about that so game day get
up
final preps and doing things like this
joke of Dave under the table is also
what's keeping me sane because that's
something else makes it fun and
beautiful to focus on just to let a
little little pressure exactly and those
are in many ways the things that really
matter in some ways about just being a
human being and you know friendships and
relationships and all those things so I
get there just double check the props
I've got backups of everything and also
I've spent the last few days trying to
write a script
while you're there while I'm there
because I'm not I'm not good at
scripting I'm not good at script writing
I've always found it very hard
you're like writing a totally unrelated
screenplay all right script meeting for
the ACT well I was writing some
unrelated software that's a separate
stories
and usually my process for quote unquote
scripting is I sort of work out roughly
what I want the thing to be about and I
go to the literal figurative open mic
and I think of it like sketching a line
you do a lot of like light sketches and
gradually find the shape of the line
until you thicken it and thicken it and
find the actual the Bold line and that's
sort of usually how I work on material
so meaning that you would have a few
bullets and then you would improv yeah
and
you would gradually find the right
sculpting exactly of the words that are
the connective tissue between those
bullet points or even how to articulate
those bullet points in the moment I know
semantically the idea I want to get
across and the words I discover what
words come out of me in that moment and
for whatever reason for me I found
that's the best way to find the real
stuff because in that moment in the
spotlight it's more real and I then
record all the shows and go oh oh those
words are good today yeah damn what did
I say oh that's good [__] I'll say that
again next time and that's slowly how
the script emerges most the time I don't
necessarily think that's a good way to
work but it's the way I've got that I've
found yeah but for this one it's like I
want to kind of have this nailed and I
failed to write this script I keep
trying I've got friends who are like
come on write your script like we're
gonna I'm like I'm on it I'm gonna do it
lock myself in the room for an hour
can't do it brain just slips off the
task so on the day I don't have a script
and I'm like you know what I'm just
going to accept that I wish I did I
didn't it is what it is and I hit up a
friend Jared and an amazing magician who
is also there just hanging out uh
performing
and there's this one line I kind of want
to nail the ending line I know what I'm
going to open with and I know a bunch of
key phrases that I'm going to be good
and I'm confident I've got through this
many times in rehearsal and it's always
a little bit different but it's fine
there's this one bit at the end that
it's a chance to give it the final line
before the ending I don't I've never
like worked out what to say there and
Jared is just an amazing human being
philosopher writer speaker and we sort
of have a we overlap a lot in some of
our theories of magic and
he's like sort of me but more poetic and
philosophical and so I hit him up I'm
like hey I'm trying to figure out this
line and we just sit down and the
competition's going on I'm the second
last Act of the whole day of like the 15
competitors that on the Friday
and we just sit down and there's this
odd ironic zen-like calm because I've
now done everything the preparation's
over it's in that sort of pecan before
the storm we've done everything we
realistically could
and we just chat about this final line
and it's this beautiful peaceful moment
of just him and I these little grizzled
Veterans of this bizarre art form just
going yeah what's this want to be and we
figure out sort of a line for it I'm
like that's pretty good thanks thanks
man we'll see if I remember it in the
moment because I don't know we don't
know what's gonna happen
and then backstage and again a couple of
friends Dom and shoot are there going
okay we have this term being the special
agent which again is like the
non-violent Jason Bourne just the person
who's capable motivated and just on top
of whatever inevitably is going to go
wrong because something is so this is
like your
A-Team fixer yes exactly yeah and I I'm
often that for other friends as well and
so we all take turns like who's just on
it and gets it and is there when Don
went on America's Got Talent I was his
special agent I'm like we're there we're
ready just gonna deal with whatever's
gonna happen
and so he's there and it's great and
it's calm and then I do the stupid video
joke because I've realized some
experience
going on stage at something like that is
terrifying
and I've realized that it helps me to
have something else to think about and
that's part of the reason why jokes like
that are funny little side projects
there are a couple of other ones that
are other stories
and one thing I Love Actually that's
relevant at fism I've been there five
times I've competed three times attended
two times and something that has
happened every single time
is a contestant will go out and begin
their act and something will go wrong
they'll have a fumble or a clear issue
or a lighting problem that they have to
pause
and you've got this audience of up to 3
000 magicians from all over the world
and every time this happens someone has
kind of an awkward fumble moment
the audience like applauds supportively
in that sort of nice quiet Applause to
say like they know how scary it is and
how much bravery it takes to walk out on
that stage and it's like we see you we
got you even if we're hoping someone
else wins we want everyone to at least
be able to do a great job we want to see
something amazing and it's just it's
every damn time it makes me choke up
slightly when I see that happen it's
that's lovely it's my favorite damn
thing about the whole thing it's and
it's not true for all communities no
there are really hyper competitive
communities and then there are others
that seem to be
really supportive in that way yeah
everyone there is most people there's a
few narcissists and [__] and
everything but mostly people are there
worshiping at the ultra Rwanda they want
to feel the thing they want to see
people be able to do the thing and I
know that as well and that also helps me
I'm going out there to a warm room it's
always warm people want to be amazed
they want you to be good and you just
have to not screw it up so I go out and
I do the thing and it goes okay and I
bring the person up and I do the thing
I'm going to create this moment that
then is going to linger beyond the end
of it
and it goes okay and the new bit goes
fine it goes really well it's one of
those rare Beautiful Moments where the
thing goes as you planned usually things
don't it takes a lot of iterations to
get through it it just works and it's
just ah it's deeply satisfying I do the
thing I give the person to the person
they go back all the lines land all the
moments hit
and um I go you know then blah thank you
you know good night and it gets the
whole room of the stands up to applaud
it gets a full Standing Ovation which
again I did not expect I was just trying
to focus on I just want to do the thing
and not [__] the bed just gonna get
through this with it with my janky ass
half written script and remember the
line that Jared gave me and like just
trying I'm just completely focused on
getting through it again not knowing how
it's going to be perceived I've learned
that I just don't know it might be great
it might be terrible and the main thing
they're very strict time limits minimum
five minutes maximum 10 minutes a minute
over a second over under you get
disqualified and I think the theory is
your professional you should be able to
keep within a five percent range get it
together and I still remember when
everyone's standing up to applaud my
main thought is wait am I is this going
to put this system
oh God can I like is this I don't know
they're still applauding this is not
getting but luckily there's a timer I
can look at and we're only at like eight
minutes future so I'm like oh okay thank
God all right we're fine we're fine we
can accept the Applause it's great
oh man and I feel awkward about it like
it's it's that weird duality of it's
it's lovely like the recognition is
beautiful but also I also feel very
awkward about it at the same time I'm a
shy ass introvert I mask very
effectively and pretend not to be but
I'm shy and awkward in most situations
and this is definitely one of them so
I'm like uh don't look at me but also
thanks I really appreciate it it's
complicated so finally I'm like all
right and I just got backstage and then
the moment happens the riot happens the
friends like come out and look at this
I'm like oh my God like what that's this
crowd is gather around the person with
the object and they're taking photos and
examining it and this and there's a
whole bunch of photos out there of
people just looking like they're getting
high Jordan showed me a photo sort of a
diagonal top-down photo from someone who
had that vantage point of this yeah and
the variety of extreme facial
expressions
is tremendous yeah you have some people
are they look like they're inspecting a
diamond right they're really trying to
scrutinize you have one guy I think he
had a very short white beard who just he
looks like he's blissed out on cloud
nine and Opium Den yeah
he's just soaking it in yep he was wild
yeah he's taking in his communion with
Wonder yeah and wouldn't experience
right and then thank God it's over and
shoot and I had been joking for weeks
about yeah we were so tired we were
giving it everything we had let's just
try and let's we're doing this once this
is also the only time I'm ever going to
do this again I'm never going to enter
another magic competition after that at
the time is what I'm thinking I'm like
this is the shot so I want to give it
everything I want to at least give it
the chance to just Bloom and to be
whatever it's going to be I don't want
to think you know what if I want to just
give it a shot because this is either
way this is the end of this 10-year
story arc for this routine one way or
the other and so now shoot and I like oh
my God we're done thank God now we can
actually join the party and celebrate
and relax and it's great but the way
this thing works is they do all the
preliminaries there's eight different
categories three subcategories of
close-up magic five sub categories would
you mind just mentioning some of the
categories sure so under close-up magic
they have General close-up magic they
call it micro magic which is just
European for close-up magic basically
parlor magic which is more medium scale
and then card magic gets its own
category as a specialist in medium scale
refers to the size of the props are the
audience yeah so normally and these
categories are sort of I would debate
whether these are useful categories but
the way they Define it is closet magic
is done where you can physically touch
the audience where you're in physical
proximity it's truly close up
parlor magic is more for sort of 50 to
100 people in a more stand-up situation
generally again that's an
oversimplification but that's kind of
how they roughly Define it it's always
been nebulous and blurry and what are
some of the outside of the subcategories
of close-up magic what are some of the
other categories so under stage magic
they have General stage magic
manipulation which is heavy sleight of
hand focused so so difficult dexterity
to give the illusion of impossibility
State Grand Illusion which is like big
box tricks basically not really my thing
but big box like cutting someone in half
yeah the cutting a person in half is the
classic big box Grand Illusion as they
call it mentalism the illusion of mind
reading or fake psychological abilities
or whatever and comedy magic it gets its
own category which again is an odd false
dichotomy is all over the place but
that's that's fine add some space
exactly makes it interesting
and the way it works is they award a
first second and third prize in each of
these eight categories and one things I
really respect about fism because again
it has many flaws it's not perfect by
long shot but I respect that the judges
don't have to award any of the prizes
if an act isn't upstairs they don't have
to award the first prize for example and
often they don't oh interesting the
theory is so it's not a ranked Podium
finish it you could have the top winner
in a category get the equivalent of
second place you could yeah no one gets
first and that does happen that has
happened many times in its history they
try to make it mean something over the
decade I love that yeah I really respect
no great inflation yep absolutely yeah
it's not just who's best on the day it's
like is this good enough by the
standards we've sort of admittedly
arbitrarily subjectively said but yeah I
respect that intent what a just a breath
of fresh air right that's kind of cool
making mean something right exactly and
obviously it's subjective how do you
judge art should you try and judge art
should you even have competitions these
are very reasonable questions but at
least they're kind of trying they're
generally going in and then of the the
winners the first prizes
they have the option but not the
obligation to give out one overall
quote-unquote Grand Prix you know it's
French big prize for overall close-up
and overall stage the two big Mega
prizes that they don't have to award but
that's the big final thing
but shoot and I like we're done it's
great it's over thank God we get to
relax and finally party and hang out
and then one of the organizers comes up
to us and goes um I forget the words but
like uh yeah be ready to perform again
tomorrow which is simultaneously amazing
and terrible news it's amazing what
about the cheesecake
damn it ah horrible horrible success and
this is incredible because we're pretty
sure we don't know for certain this is
implies we have probably it seems likely
we have probably won our categories or
you can tie for first they can offer
like a special prize you never quite
know there's a lot of exception cases
throughout history that have happened so
we're like probably means which is a
weird place to be we're like we think
that means we might have won our
category definitely means I shouldn't
get blackout drunk it definitely means
we have to do it again tomorrow and it's
and it felt exactly like like getting to
the end of a marathon
having given it everything to make it to
the finish and suddenly needs to run
another five miles and we're just like
oh my God oh God and we just we did not
prepare for this we did not think this
was what was going to happen and so we
go back to the hotel room and start
prepping for another performance and for
both of us in different ways that's a
non-trivial undertaking and it's like oh
God damn it but also amazing oh my God
this is incredible what oh my God what a
like it's such a complex yin and yang of
emotion yeah the sort of genus faced
blessing exactly oh yeah and so we then
get some sleep and get up the next day
and go into preparation mode and again
that that day is its own insane story of
all kinds of weird things went wrong the
first placement is all perform again
this time for all 12 judges the close-up
and Stage judges joined together to
judge everything so the close-ups
haven't seen the stage thing look stage
judges haven't seen the close-ups
they're all now going to watch them and
judge are any of these acts worthy of
the Grand Prix and if so which one for
each
and 10 minutes before walking out for
that performance I am in the stairwell
the fire escape stairwell in my t-shirt
and jeans not my suit fixing a problem
with one of the props that has gone
wrong for reasons it's a whole story
there are visual aids it's a separate
thing it's and again
Dominion never I'm not surprised because
they're like yeah classic Carnel this
it's always like this I'm like yeah I
wish that wasn't true but it is yeah one
day I'll be fully ready for a
performance one day it'll be great and
at that point I'm thinking if it comes
down to it I would rather walk out in my
crappy T-shirt and jeans with a trick
that works than in my nice stage suit
with a trick that doesn't work luckily
we get both barely so I walk out on
stage fighting the trembles like I'm I'm
adrenaline soaked and haven't had time
to get in the zone at all but I do the
thing it goes okay I'm freaking out but
holding it together no one can tell the
Tremor is very slight in the hand but I
keep it together
and the person the different person I
bring up is amazed and it works well and
I'm like now it's over thank God God
damn now we're actually done and so then
there's a few hours while the judges
deliberate and then there's going to be
the awards ceremony
and the awards ceremony is the first
time we find out what actually happened
and it turns out that shoot wins first
prize in parlor magic which is amazing
and wonderful and I tie for first in
close-up magic in micro magic which is
incredible holy [__] I just wanted to
make this thing real and I was so happy
back in 2009 to tithe third now I one
day I'll get my own award like I keep
tying for things that seems to be a
running joke and then we go back and sit
in the audience with the trophies and
this is the first moment I've had in
days if not weeks to pause for breath
I'm sitting there in the crowd amongst
friends and like um Vincent a guy from
Australia came second in parliamagic
after shoot which is amazing and Dom
went there to do a stupid joke for a
show he's working on and achieved it and
just everyone got some version of what
they came for and it's just beautiful
and all the other Prize winners I would
call it worthy because sometimes someone
wins you like ah really is that who's
the world champion of that but it was
all beautiful it was just this beautiful
moment everything was great
and I'm sitting there and when there's
150 contestants or thousands from in the
preliminaries you like
Anything Could Happen you don't know
you're up against so many people it's
you don't even think about what the
outcome is going to be so much of it's
again Epictetus right it's out of your
control but now I'm sitting there and
they're slow rolling the awards ceremony
and there's other announcements and they
announce the next one's going to be in
Italy and that's a whole thing and they
thank the sponsors and they do think I'm
sitting there holding this first place
Trophy and now thinking about wait a
minute they're still going to announce
the Grand Prix
and now rather than 150 people or
hundreds or thousands of people it's
down to four people it's me the guy I
tied with shoot and the card guy from
France I think that's slightly
embarrassing wherever he's from
and when it's one in four that's
something your brain can engage with and
I'm sitting here trying not to think
about it because the Eternal dialogue is
going don't you do this to yourself you
son of a [__] don't you do it this is
what leads to disappointment don't you
[__] think about can we swear yes you
can swear don't you [__] do this to
yourself don't you get your hopes up
because you get disappointed that is how
that happens
don't you do it but then the brain goes
well look imagine you're a fism judge
and you're thinking okay who do we give
the Grand Prix to and my brain was like
there was a riot
something happened that's never happened
before and I'm like don't shut up shut
up internal voice shut the [__] up get
the don't you do this don't don't get
the hopes up
but if this goes on for like 10 minutes
20 minutes and they're slow rolling this
thing I'm there I'd like to thank our
bronze sponsors and I'm there in this
deep internal struggle of like don't
think about it medicine remember the
mindfulness focus on the breath but then
the inner voice is like but maybe and
I'm like no and I'm thinking about it
because it's the first time I've had to
catch my breath and I am seeing about
the last year and a half and the last 10
years and the last decades and this
whole damn Journey
and it becomes very clear to me over
that half hour sitting there that if
as much as I try not to think about it
at all
if they say my name I realize I'm
absolutely going to burst into tears and
I'm not a crier I cry like once every
year or two like maybe and I realize oh
yeah there's no way it's because I'm
already like just at the memories of
like what it had taken and how what did
it cost and how much it had taken to
walk this path and get to this point and
how I never thought it would get
anywhere let alone here let alone what
I'm despite myself thinking and I
realized oh yeah I'm gonna I'm just
gonna break down and I realized in that
moment that one thing that's always made
me sad is when people cry
so often the first instinct is to hide
or apologize or pretend not to and that
always breaks my heart I wish that
weren't the case it's sad that Society
teaches us to hide that or to shove that
and I kind of decide you know what the
only thing
it's like a little side quest in my head
now at this point to just so I can not
think about it is that all we can ever
do is try to lead by example and even
that you very rarely get a chance to do
and I do you know you know was it be the
change you want in the world even if
it's in a tiny almost trivial way and I
go you know what if this happens don't
think about it don't think about it but
if but don't think about okay if it
happens I realize I'm not gonna hide it
I'm not even gonna wipe a tear away I'm
just gonna let it rip and at least I
mean I'm gonna cry at least I can do it
on my own terms
and then they say my goddamn name and as
predicted I burst into tears just
uncontrollable like convulsive sobbing
and I walk up on stage and I stand there
and the only thing I'm thinking about is
try to keep your shoulders back head up
make it clear that you are not gonna
hide and I just stand there on stage and
I find out later that the the presenter
was like awkwardly kind of expecting to
give me the mic to give a speech but
it's like I'm just like I'm just [__]
heaving and sobbing someone called it
ugly crying just like conver holding
this enormous goddamn trophy just
bawling my eyes out on stage and this
was I found out later this was live
streamed as well so I'm like okay cool
great fine and then the main phism guy
comes over and we post the photo and I'm
still just weeping and then walk off
stage and try to find a tissue
what did it feel like to let it rip
really cathodic really good it felt
right it was the right decision I mean
it's not what I would have chosen to do
if I'd had the option but it was very
clear that I was not gonna have a choice
this was gonna happen whether I wanted
to or not and so it felt good to yeah to
not hide and to not yeah not be ashamed
because that's that's what I want for
everybody else
What did the
hour or two or three after that feel
like so then they announced the stage
Grand Prix person which is this Duo from
Belgium who also did this amazing stage
act and then we come back out and then
all the winners come back out which is
you know three times eight plus a heap
of people on stage for like all the
photos and the video and to everyone to
come up and it was just this sort of so
genteel pandemonium in the in the
loveliest sense because again everyone's
there out of love and it's just had been
this beautiful thing and basically
everyone felt good about all the
announcements and just and we sort of
stood on the stage and all the official
photographers took photos and then
everyone else took photos and a bunch of
people wanted to pose for selfies and
and then eventually there's this photo
somewhere once it had sort of started to
calm down as it went from three thousand
people down to only a few hundred people
and then shoot and I just kind of sat
down on the steps at the front of the
stage and just
sat there just empty hey I completely
just huh and then and people kept coming
up and just saying oh my you know it was
great or congrats or can we get a photo
or can you sign my thing and it was just
this sort of
the first time I'd felt like sort of
clear-headed in weeks or months or just
like the catharsis of it I don't even
know how to describe it just in addition
to the catharsis were you or are you
able to in that case let's make it
specific were you able to
sit in the Afterglow
or celebrate and I ask in part because
I'm not terribly good at it yeah or were
you like
let me catch my breath and then already
he did a few days later thinking about
yeah where you might be pointed a bit of
both it was one of the many things and I
mean one thing I still haven't fully
processed it you know this was July last
year it's now April it feels like eating
a six foot wide donut I don't know how
to get all of this noise yeah I don't
I'm nibbling at it but it's not going in
it still hasn't gone in yet uh I'm still
actively figuring it out what did that
really happen I keep forgetting it
happened it's not fitting into my brain
but one of the things that came out of
it two big things one was for the first
time I felt my imposter syndrome which
nearly everyone has unless there are
raging narcissist I think everyone has
impostor syndrome to some degree I felt
it just pop like a soap bubble just a
delicate little and felt free of it
which isn't the same as having an ego or
anything because not everything I do is
good but that demon on the shoulder that
tells you no you suck you're not good
enough that was finally a big enough
event that even that demon got squashed
quiet and couldn't deem was like oh yeah
all right okay fine you can do good
stuff all right fine that was one and
the other thing was it was the first
time in my adult life since finishing
High School
that I felt like I could stop and catch
a breath for a moment because I'd never
felt that before I always felt like I
you know I hadn't proved myself I hadn't
like figured out a career I hadn't like
achieved the thing or you know there was
always something to do there was always
that pressure that forwards movement and
for the first time I felt you know what
I'm going to take a few months and just
do nothing and just sit and just regroup
and Catch My Breath because also I was
unsurprisingly massively burnt out I was
so burnt out at that point I'm not
shocked yeah right I mean pandemic alone
and everything else a lot plus all of
that but the thing that was great was
shoot and I flew back to LA
and we slept and then the next day we
did what we had been knowing for months
or over a year at this point that we
knew what we wanted to do more than
anything
and we went to a cafe and we just hung
out and had coffee
without stress or worry or the upcoming
pressure and it was perfect that was
that was what we were toying for years
you know once this is over oh man we can
just hang out and have coffee and like
that's the best possible thing the
simple things and then we went to the
Magic Castle that night just to have a
drink and we can't remember we as you
know sort of the night we flew back we
went to the Magic Castle this is before
the coffee and we kind of went you know
what let's go have a drink at the castle
why not hang out and we as we walked up
the hill to it we we were going I wonder
if anyone's heard because it had been
that day it was that same afternoon
we're like I wonder if anyone's heard I
don't know maybe maybe not
and we walk in and everyone has heard
like it was all
everyone who works there the people in
the kitchen like everybody like was the
number one news we're like oh God and
that night was amazing because what a
homecoming right and because the thing
is the Magic Castle was
I mean again it's the real place but
there had been even pre-pandemic it'll
be going through kind of a dark age in
that it had just been less inspiring
there were fewer really amazing people
hanging out there it was under
management that wasn't particularly
tapping into the beautiful wonderful
things about the place and I'd found
myself just less inclined to go there on
any given night normally you go there
and you have an amazing night and it's
incredible and you meet amazing people
and see amazing things and that had just
been happening less and less in the
Years leading up to the pandemic and
then the pandemic obviously was awful
and so many people that night mentioned
versions of you know what this feels
like this feels like the old school
Castle again and there was a Vibe people
I hadn't seen for years were there and
this is the closest I will ever come to
saying something self-congratulatory
because even just being Australian it's
like ah awkward but this was someone
else there's something someone else said
so I feel less uncomfortable about it
even though it's still very
uncomfortable
and his friend said well yeah you know
because the Magic Castle was founded
back in the 50s invert the Vernier on
having the best magic in the world was
there and that was true
and for a long time that had kind of
stopped being true and the best magic
was maybe in Madrid or South Korea or
Germany or a bunch of other places that
are these real hot spots of magical
Innovation and excellence and it hadn't
been the castle actually for a long time
and then she said in this amazingly
dramatic way but tonight that changed I
was like oh chills tingles and also I
don't know how to handle the implied
responsibility of that I'm still kind of
figuring that out I don't know I'm
mostly just not thinking about it as
much as I can so you went to have a
drink what was your drink
I had a vodka lime and soda the low
calorie options
if I'm not thinking about the calories
it's a French 75. so it is a French 75.
I think it's champagne gin lemon juice
and simple syrup sort of like a fancy
Tom Collins cheat day yeah exactly
exactly
have a long list of questions that I
liked let's go let's see if we can
answer them in less than an hour and a
half each I'm like the last one
so feeling lucky having started later
with magic yeah why is that the main
reason is a lot of good things begin
from empathy
understanding the experience of the
other person or people in so many ways
in so many fields of human endeavor
and magic in particular like you
observed earlier requires an
understanding and awareness of the Mind
Of The Observer of what's happening
perceptually and one of the things that
I think is really difficult about magic
is that once you learn how it's done it
becomes very hard to remember what it
was like to not know how it was done
totally it's very hard to maintain
empathy with the audience experience
very very difficult even more so than
most other Arts I have thought about
this I don't want to take us down a side
alley too far but I'll let out a secret
that we probably won't have time to
unpack today but you speak Chinese very
well I do mandarin and I've spent time
in China I've spent time in Japan and I
often wonder what it used to be like to
look at Japanese or Chinese
writing yeah when it just looked
illegible yep but I can't revert
absolutely and it's similar it is very
hard to maintain that sense of what it
is actually like to literally see the
magic to see the thing that looks
impossible because you can't once you
know and I think I see a lot of
magicians who get into it when they're
younger there's often this disconnect of
so I have very clear memories as an
adult technically legally legal adult
18. I can remember seeing what are
considered in the magic industry very
sort of simple almost beginner tricks
and I can remember the visceral memory
of being profoundly affected by them and
being profoundly amazed I run to many
magicians like not the good ones the
good ones get it the good ones
understand who have long ago lost touch
with the power of these Illusions
they're like oh that's just basic listen
man do not underestimate the power of
that because I have those memories still
and those guide so much of my creative
process with magic of like I remember
what it felt like to see these things
just barely like I try to hold those
memories because they're so precious and
valuable because they yeah give enable
that empathy with the audience right so
you can position switch in a sense yeah
perhaps more effectively than people who
started so young that their reference
set of experience exactly yep makes it
very hard to stand in for the audience
yeah and it's still hard for me but less
hard all right so we hop skipped and
jumped across a few lily pads and
Consulting was in there yeah at one
point
and so Accenture I'd like to talk about
that that's a name that a lot of people
will recognize very well respected
yeah it depends on the point in time but
yeah and but a recognizable absolutely
it looks like Fortune 300 company yeah
at least back when I worked there it's
huge huge yeah so I guess a few
questions related to that the first is
diving into some phrasing that you used
that I think I'm
capturing accurately which is you said
that Accenture played to some of your
weaknesses yeah what do you mean by that
I mean this sort of gets into the and
this this is the thing that again I as I
mentioned earlier I feel very sort of I
don't know nervous timid about talking
about because I've spent most of my life
adult life actively avoiding hiding the
neurodivergent stuff you know and I
figured why not when you ask me on this
is a good chance to just rip off the
Band-Aid you know and the most public
possible Arena we're going to the honest
truthful phase of my life or something
but um in my early 20s I was diagnosed
with at the time Asperger's Syndrome
like high functioning autism spectrum
thing which uh to the surprise of no one
at the time so many people have the same
experience it was a relief I was like oh
that's why all that stuff was confusing
and awkward and didn't make sense it's
bad news like it's not good news but at
least it makes sense there's some
explanatory yeah at least I kind of now
know what we're working with and can
start the incredibly long difficult
process of working out what to do about
that and that then was the next couple
of Decades of my life trying to work out
what to do about that and how to learn
those skills that weren't there
naturally and learn how to you know read
nonverbal signals and communication and
just all that that's still ongoing is
still a challenge every day it's a pain
in the ass but there are worse problems
I don't know so human interaction is
challenging it's difficult there's extra
layers there's a lot of extra thinking
and Analysis to figure out and in a high
pressure business environment there's a
lot of that and so it was a lot of
situations I found very awkward and
uncomfortable and stressful even more so
than they would be for anybody I think
although it's like trying to figure out
what is universal and what is unique and
the answer is lots of both
and also I'm now realizing I spent so
many years focused on like trying to
work around that and make up for those
deficits and do the extra work to deal
with it that is now increasingly
apparent that I probably also have some
kind of executive function disorder
situation going on maybe ADHD maybe
something else I'm not going to
self-diagnose I'm going to wait till I
can actually get to a professional to
deal with that because again things I
didn't realize weren't Universal
difficulty with scheduling with
remembering things keeping track of time
being organized organizing data things
like that all the kinds of things that
you're doing a lot of in a high pressure
high-powered business strategy
Consulting environment and I was doing
okay I was getting the job done and
doing a pretty okay job of it but it was
just exhausting it was killing me to do
so all the extra cognitive load to deal
with some of those things that are not
easy for anybody necessarily but we're
like extra exhausting and at the time I
was you know I now have learned the term
masking hiding it trying to you know do
the work to pretend to not be dealing
with this stuff because for all the
reasons that people learn to do that
sure and learn that they should and I'm
only just now kind of going you know
what what if we try not doing that what
if we sort of acknowledge it and I think
one of the reasons I hit it was I've
just seen so many people use it as an
excuse or a crutch where they're just
kind of being an [__] and go oh I
want the autism spectrum so it's okay
I'm like what no you're still just an
[__] and I think I'd seen too much of
that that I wanted to make sure I didn't
give myself that out that I didn't give
myself the crutch there's a quote from
Terry Pratchett is one of my favorite
authors amazing author I love God that
man I feel so lucky to have gotten to
his books when I was at like early
teenager learned so much about just
being a human being in the best way and
one of his characters granny Weather Wax
one of the witches who's just an amazing
character there was this quote she says
to one of the other witches that yeah
the hard way is pretty hard but it's not
nearly as hard as the easy way
and there's deep wisdom there but I
think maybe I ran too far with that I
think maybe I made it too hard for
myself and that's been good now let's
try maybe acknowledging it a bit so yeah
it's very scary and very intimidating
well I appreciate you being so candid I
know that there are many people not only
in my audience but there are many people
in my audience who have children who
also fit this profile many of my very
close friends are right now have
neurodiverging children
so it gives them permission to also have
conversations which is important if we
look at Accenture at the job I find this
of interest to put under a microscope
for a little bit because it's also a
path that contrasts with maybe some of
the often apocryphal but storied
histories of say magicians or authors
who
throw caution to the wind
and if you're going to be a writer write
God damn it and they don't have a backup
plan and they're just living hand to
mouth barely making ends meet and they
figure out a way to make writing
financially viable but then there's the
other track which I would say
just based on what I'm hearing this
would fit into which is similar to say a
friend of mine who's a very successful
novelist
and even after he had had one or two New
York Times bestsellers he still had an
s.a.t Tutoring company
very small I mean it was a I think he
was a solo proprietor but he kept it
running because he didn't want to feel
too much pressure
imposed on his creative love and what he
hoped would have wings but that he
didn't want to bet on yeah
and there are sort of philosophical
differences here and one is give
yourself no options that you take the
only options exactly burn the boats the
other is
a good idea to have a little bit of
savings maybe a little bit of stability
so that you can develop your craft
without having to make a lot of creative
compromises how did you feel during this
process when you were basically Bruce
Wayne by day Batman by night or on the
weekends it's a very generous analogy
but I'll take I'll take I'm feeling
generous today and
and how did you make the decision to go
full time what did that process look
like I realized when I joined Accenture
I joined it with the intent of sort of
doing it for a couple of years seeing
what it was like get enough experience
on the resume that it would hold its
value that was at least the conventional
wisdom at the time and then do something
else like start a startup or like Go
full magic or something I didn't really
know and I remember before I joined
Accenture there was this like I think I
was also lucky to get into magic late
because I was just barely wise enough to
make some smart choices barely wisdom is
a heavy word for what you have when
you're 18 but lowercase wisdom yeah
compared to a nine-year-old right you've
got a little yeah very nice
and when I joined Accenture I realized I
had this sort of flash forward to going
yeah I'm young and idealistic I'm going
to join for a couple years then quit and
do something you know that leads me
towards something whatever I don't know
and I just had a sudden flicker of like
wait a minute I've heard the story I've
heard how this can go and then very
common you blink and you're 40 in middle
management and wondering where the
decades went and I kind of sensed uh
wait that could be me you never know who
you are until you're there in the moment
until you're faced with the actual
trolley lever right you don't know which
what you'll do
and so I went on this round the world
pilgrimage with all my remaining savings
at the time it was the first time I came
to America to see the Magic Castle to
see Vegas and all the soaked aslay shows
and all the stuff I'd heard of and this
is before this is before Accenture this
was in the monthly because I realized it
was going to be a while before I had
free time I was going to go into this
high pressure corporate environment and
I did it as kind of a almost created
pilgrimage to kind of I thought it was
like almost injecting inspiration into
intravenously to kind of keep that fire
burning stockpile some fire exactly hide
my soul in my sock where they can't find
it and drag it into the corporate
drudgery that was sort of the my idea
the mindset at the time and I think that
was good because I did have a sense I
wanted to do something but I didn't know
what or when and so at Accenture while I
was there and earning a you know okay
salary I still lived pretty frugally and
I stockpiled savings I deliberately
didn't buy a car even though I could
have afforded one and instead I spent
the money on trips to the US to keep
getting inspired and connecting and
everything and building savings I didn't
live extravagantly because I kind of had
a sense whatever's next I don't know
what's next but it's going to be good to
have a stockpile of savings and then I
realized that the phrase I wrote once in
a diary entry was fear and enthusiasm
battled and fear kept winning I'm like I
want to leave and do something cool and
do the thing and Go full magic or
something but ah it's scary I don't feel
ready
and then finally after sort of three
more I was at the company for five years
and after three years longer than I
intended to be just out of fear and out
of the golden handcuffs and the
stability and one day finally some
pieces clicked together in my head there
was an actual moment where I realized
I'd read an article by a palliative care
nurse about our observations on people's
end-of-life regrets and the number one
as is well documented is that they never
tried the thing
then try the thing always wanted never
found out and I realized yeah I don't
want to die that way I want to know even
if it fails at least you know sorry okay
number one I have to try the thing
number two I'd been waiting until I felt
ready enough savings and enough like
career contacts enough good magic
material or whatever and I realized I
was a perfectionist and I was never
gonna feel ready and so number three if
there's no right time then sooner is
better than later
and I've started drafting my resignation
letter like it was one of those rare
moments normally life doesn't work with
these epiphanies but that was one where
it was there was a b c it was a simple
equation it was an algorithm I'm like
yep that logically checks out
all right [__] I guess I'm doing it and
in your mind
did you think to yourself
something along the lines of the
management of strategy Consulting it's
like okay I'm going to do this for X
number of years
to accumulate a b and c
and then assess course or do the thing
completely right so with magic did you
have something similar you're like okay
I'm not going to leave this open-ended
I'm going to say travel to La I'm gonna
be in the thick of things I'm going to
give it six months or 12 months and then
reassess or was it like okay come hell
or high water it was something in
between the two it definitely wasn't the
former there was no plan I just went for
it I think I just went out there again
sort of I kept The Beginner's mind I'm
just going I don't know what's going to
happen let's go and find out let's jump
into it with full strength and full
intensity and just reevaluate as we go I
think that's the only way to sort of
again be like water right stay open no
fixed positions in the in the martial
art see what happens and it basically
didn't work which is the weird twist my
full-time job was magic for the next 10
years and I would say I failed at it I
mostly lived off those savings I was
earning money but not enough the savings
were dwindling and most of those years
safe space no one else is listening it's
fine it's just us Tim for that 10 years
I mostly earned poverty line or below
income for those 10 years it was hard
because the tragedy is what gets
Financial Success is Not artistic
ability it's networking client
relationship management negotiating
etc etc so those business skills that
replying to emails in a timely manner
all that stuff that I just did not have
at all or being able to find the right
people but again shy introverted
spectrumy type I wasn't good at finding
people I was good at connecting with
people I really felt resonance with but
they often weren't the ones who could
build my career and I just never found a
way to make it work and in the end when
the puzzles came along I was so ready to
be done with it I love the magic but not
the business of it and you have though
at least for the show that I saw
assembled a core team of people who do
compliment which is amazing weaknesses
and it is the first time I've really
felt this and it is I feel a lot like I
think a lot about the Parable is that
the right word of the cat who sits on
the hot stove and gets burnt and it
learns not to sit on the hot stove but
it also doesn't sit on the cold stove
yeah and I've been thinking about that a
lot recently about looking back over my
experiences in the 10 years I was
full-time magic and going oh God no but
maybe it's a different stove now I
haven't made conclusions on that yet I
don't know but Chad rabinovitz the
director and producer of the show who's
amazing incredible magic director of
which there are not many in the world
you might be the only good magic
director in North America that I know of
he nudged me to do this he went come we
should get this show up and I'm like oh
God damn it no professional magic sucks
I felt it it was bad it wasn't for me
I'm done with it he's like come on let's
do the show and I'm like you know what I
would like this to happen there's
creatively and I'm like I don't know
maybe it doesn't have to be a failure
this time I'm not sure I don't know
so I wanted to to highlight that that
you have this core team now and
then we will talk about the puzzles
before we get there I have a whole slew
of
miscellaneous that I need to address her
that's going to bother me so the first
is
hotbeds of magical Innovation I'm always
fascinated Within These subcultures of
which locations seem to be producing
interesting things and I just wrote down
Madrid South Korea Germany yeah and
before we start recording we were also
looking at some of the tabletop games
that have behind me which I'm testing
out and there are certain places that
just take tabletop gaming very seriously
Germany would absolutely
In The World of Magic
what are the top
High concentration spots for magic
Innovation I think the biggest one right
now is probably South Korea the South
Korean magic scene is extraordinary
right now and it really the rest of the
world found out about it I think it
would have been roughly 2012 at fism the
one that I got the weird originality
prize out when a guy called yuho Jin on
the stage Grand Prix it's still one of
those just defining moments I remember
in my life of being there just in the
audience hanging out I'd competed on
like the first day like you know got it
off and acts come out and yuhojin comes
out and just it is transcendent it just
does it's just amazing it's yeah well
there's Grand Prix moments that
captivates everybody and I remember
afterwards just instant Standing Ovation
I remembered thinking I'm just going to
stand here and applaud until I cannot
physically applaud anymore like I'm just
gonna clap these hands until they fall
off I'm just that is amazing and this
was the world kind of going oh my God
and there were a bunch of other South
Korean magicians there as all who also
Place very highly numbers going what is
happening in South Korea
I'm not qualified to speak to the
details of it but apparently there'd
been this you know there was the Korean
War in the North Korean situation and it
had been like this artistic slump for a
long time but then a couple of people
there had really done a lot to
re-incubate it and this amazingly
collaborative scene had emerged where
they were like really innovating there
was Government funding I think like Arts
Council funding that was helping as well
and just to this day just South Korea
it's really exciting I was literally
just having a conversation yesterday
with this entrepreneur and also a very
very skilled writer and in Bobby
hundreds who's here in LA
famous for creating the iconic
streetwear brand and he is
korean-american
and we were talking about South Korea
because there are so many sectors
in which South Korea just comes out of
seemingly nowhere and begins to dominate
that's true and of all things break
dancing for many years they had the best
break dancers in the world the most
Innovative they were doing things people
didn't think was even in the realm of
possibility for human bodies to produce
this would include even comparing them
to Olympic gymnasts I mean they're doing
some of the most incredible things
anyone had ever seen and then you have
desktop gaming right PC gaming archery
they've been the most dominant in
Olympic archery no close second place
for ever and this is something I want to
study so I'll just make another note
South Korea absolutely revisit South
Korea yeah you were mentioning the
categories of magic hmm
in the fism competition and I'm
wondering
if there are any particular experts
or Specialists they don't have to be
Specialists but people who are
particularly impressive to you in the
world of mentalism
the uh my opinions on mentalism
start with your opinions on mentalism
yeah I I am not a fan of mentalism uh
all right oh God this is gonna get me
hate mail
so what the hell radical honesty let's
go so again they see this is not
Universal there are exceptions to this
there are wonderful people who do
mentalism some of them are friends
they're cool but and for people who
don't remember the definition maybe you
could just Define the term
mentalism broadly you could Define it as
uh Magic used to create rather than the
illusion of Vanishing and reappearing
and things like that you used to create
the illusion of psychic or psychological
abilities that you do not have think of
a number from one to Seventeen yeah oh
my God you got it right holy [__] you
must have either psychic powers or like
really good body language NLP stuff that
overwhelmingly is not the case here's
the thing is oh boy oh this is really
gonna this is really gonna piss some
people off can't please everyone you
really can't here's the thing one of the
things I realized back when I first got
into magic I was really intrigued by
mentalism because how would you not be
it's a compelling it's powerful it gets
a reaction of course you feel like all
the things that many of the things that
draw you to it but I eventually realized
that a very common I've always held the
Golden Rule Tuesday would be done by
ethical reciprocity doesn't always work
because people are different but it's a
pretty good place to start from
and I remembered way back
seeing a magician as a teenager and
being Amazed by something going oh yeah
how did you do that it's a natural
healthy scientific question and getting
like a glib dismissive reply and I was
like this guy's an [__] I felt
dismissed I didn't feel good and so when
finding myself on the other side of that
interaction I take it very seriously and
I realize that the things I do magically
personally are all things where if
someone goes how did you do that I have
to hide the method to keep it amazing
but I can go it's a combination of
sleight of hand and misdirection and a
bunch of other complicated things to
create the illusion of a thing that
definitely didn't happen the coin didn't
actually disappear I did a bunch of
complicated [__] to make it look like it
disappeared and that is the truth that
is the literal truth of what happened
so you can give them a lot of the truth
without ruining it I don't know if this
is too much of a reveal we can take it
out if you want but you do a fair amount
of this Ian glitches in reality yeah and
do you explain some of the elements and
Bob and weave in a very interesting
dance which I really enjoyed and it is
very much doing as I would be done by
right that is how I would like to be
treated by so you can do that with what
you do yeah and also if people do say
find out the actual method all of them I
think stand up is yeah that's wow that's
intriguing that I'm proud of it I'm not
going to be ashamed by the revelation of
the truth it's not like oh no I'm ruined
I'm a fraud now yeah I did what I claim
to do we did clever complicated sneaky
stuffed up but with mentalism I found
when I was doing it and people said oh
my God how did you know I was thinking
of 17. I realized I couldn't tell them
any of the truth without completely
destroying the illusion because with
mentalism what you are claiming to do is
completely false you are claiming a
category of value you absolutely do not
have it is all a lie you know like one
percent yeah maybe sometimes you kind of
take a guess and read a bit of body
language but that's like one percent of
it maybe and I just didn't feel
comfortable with that because I also
realized doing magic I meet people
through I've met you through magic we
literally married a show
and I realized if I was doing a
mentalism show you would be impressed by
me doing things that I absolutely can't
do and the foundation of our
relationship would be based on a lie and
I realized I didn't want to live that
way if I meet friends or you know dating
context or whatever I don't want our
relationship to you based on
a fundamental miscategorization of my
art craft job abilities and I just I
think again exceptions I think you kind
of have to be a bit of a sociopath to be
okay with that and again or have not
really thought it through and I think a
lot of lovely people who are mentalists
I think they just haven't really thought
through what the ramifications of what
they're actually doing are the social
ramifications yeah yeah the social or
the cultural what if you open your act
by saying I have none of these abilities
yeah if you precede your act with that
disclaimer
does that solve the problem or not
really it helps someone like Darren
Brown who is a masterful show a
beautiful human being and again one of
the people I would call mostly an
exception but the problem is I think it
doesn't quite like a show Miracle right
oh God yeah as an example Darren's
amazing like incredibly incredible
inspiration but like even Darren who
goes out of his way to kind of be a you
know servant of the truth I don't think
there's any disclaimer strong enough
because the Illusions are so powerful
and so compelling that people are still
going to go oh yeah yeah the disclaim is
fake obviously you have some kind of
actual powers and these things are
actually possible and real and they're
just not and it just makes me
uncomfortable I don't know I'm not going
to say mentalism's evil or anything you
know come on I need my headline on
YouTube yeah right I'm kidding but it's
just it I just it it makes me
uncomfortable I can't dust yeah it's not
my thing so you don't have to name names
which is what I was sort of going for
with my initial question but if we skip
that yeah are there magicians broadly
speaking and you could look at this
question in a way that makes sense who
have just such a ability to compute or
do unusual things mentally
that stand out to you I would imagine
there are types of performances where
there's a lot that you need to sort of
hold in working memory yeah I don't I
don't know I'm just I'm just kind of
speculating put it this way I'm probably
paraphrasing as best I can tella from
pennantella who is an extraordinarily
brilliant performer in person talks
about the fact that often the method to
a lot of magic is just that no one would
ever imagine you went to as much effort
as you actually did to do a thing half
the times the secrets are hidden by the
being so off the scale
crazy extent of effort and work that
Norm it wouldn't even occur to someone
and sometimes something you watch all
the time is people see a magic trick and
often guess the method correctly and
then talk themselves out of it going
maybe he whatever whatever no no one
would do that it's a what is I have no
idea and they will actually get it and
then go it couldn't be that that's
ridiculous now because it seems too
simplistic or it just seems like too
much work both sometimes a sometimes b
sometimes both together magic is so much
broader and so much deeper than people
ever realize there are so many different
rooms in the House of Magic you could
spend 10 lifetimes on it and not even
get close to everything there is to know
and learn so given that the
breadth and depth is I mean hesitate to
say infinite but just beyond the scope
of anything one human could digest let
alone Master yeah
if say someone wanted to as an adult
delve into the World of Magic yeah as a
practitioner not to become a
professional yeah but to
experiment with something that might be
enjoyable
to become more aware of perceptual
faculties and how perception can be
shaped
how might they start right because if
it's to say baseball or a given sport
you're like okay we can break this down
to a few components we can practice
those components here's a logical
progression
so we can put a through F in some type
of logical buildup yeah
if I said I would love to experiment
with magic somehow how would we even
navigate that and what questions might
you ask me or what recommendations might
you make yeah because I know there's so
many different types and so on I think
the the truest answer is it's hard there
isn't an easy answer again we can only
ever speak for ourselves I'm always wary
of advice because all advice is wrong
for somebody everyone's situation is so
different totally I found that I again
when I was a kid I had a magic set and I
had a few Magic books and none of them
helped me I concluded I was terrible at
Magic and had no potential which tells
you something about you know those books
and those kits and for me what made the
difference was
going to that University Club and having
a person to guide me because a good
teacher teaching's hard teaching is a
complex art and craft
and I teach a lot of magic I used to
teach beginner magic courses in
Melbourne at this organization and I
still sometimes take on students if it's
you know the right kind of person and
the schedule allows is you know there's
the job of the teacher to adapt to the
student and having a person to see what
I was struggling with the unique
struggles I was having that everyone
wouldn't and then we adapt to that and
guide that knowing you know whether it's
you or someone what is it you want to
achieve why you want to get to Magic
what do you want out of life that is
making you think about magic these are
all relevant questions that will then
affect what you would teach and how you
would teach it and you know what that
Journey would be yeah I would say it's
the pervasive add meaning R deficiency
disorder that I think humans suffer from
increasingly this despondent nihilism
yep where there is severe deficiency in
moments of awe yeah and the ability to
conjure that
simply or maybe not simply but
both in learning the skill myself yep
but also to provide those moments even
it's just for kids who maybe aren't
going to discern what I'm doing as
easily as an adult that's fine I mean I
don't want to perform a birthday party
so maybe it makes sense for me to
practice for adults yeah the only let's
call it magic book that ever clicked for
me yeah and I didn't take it seriously
this was a gift but I did buy a handful
of books here and there yeah and similar
to your experience most of them was like
I'm not good at this I can't do it this
doesn't work there is one very short
book and it was basically
science magic tricks it was very
straightforward it was like okay here's
how you can take a fork and a spoon and
say shove them together and use a
toothpick to balance it on the side of a
glass and it just blows people's minds
it doesn't seem to make any sense and
then you can burn the ends of the
toothpick and it looks insane
and you can pick it up and
two minutes and then demonstrate it and
that was extremely gratifying for me I
also just like learning new things
taking it seriously for a period of time
and seeing what comes of it it's like
okay if I did a Sprint
for a few weeks
with magic whatever that would end up
meaning
what could I do right and there are
certain things that go through my mind
where I'm looking at for instance some
of the demonstrations that you did
very strong opener by the way in the
show I love the opening I'm just looking
at some of the things you can do with
your hands I'm like okay there's no
[__] way that I'm going to develop
that in a few weeks also because I
simply just don't have much like
learning to speak Mandarin it's like you
can take someone who's never spoken
Mandarin and try to get them even if
they have very good hearing to mimic
some of the tones and sounds they're not
going to have the musculature yeah and
the control in their
throat in their vocal cords to produce
those sounds it doesn't matter how smart
they are yeah similarly I'm like okay I
probably am not going to develop the
attributes to do some of a lot of what
you can do
but I wonder what I could do in a
shorter period yeah and you could if you
gave it long enough but that may not be
a thing that you care enough to do and
there's nothing wrong with that so when
you're teaching let's say these
introductory courses what did the course
look like so it always began with
exactly that question like and I usually
kept it about 10 to 15 people now it's
more one-on-one or very small groups
usually on the occasions I do it and it
was always going around and asking first
of all why is everyone here like why are
you here what do you want are you hoping
to get out of this and let's see if we
can find an overlap that we can achieve
and also ask if they've ever either
learned a martial art or played a sport
or learned a musical instrument
or even just learn to drive a manual car
and I'm looking for some way I can like
find an analogous experience of going up
like a Mastery journey of like going
from I have no idea how to do this thing
and now I can do this thing because a
lot of people just tap out they get
demotivated and they they are they under
the missed the common misconception that
it's about natural Talent or natural
dexterity that oh my hands are not big
enough or not dexterous enough or I
won't be able to do this and it's like
no well you you learn that other thing
you'll be able to learn this and that's
trying to find a way to reach them
because I know from experience that's
one of the common stumbling bits and
then usually starting by teaching a
couple of basic tricks and I always go
for get some instant gratification right
because you want to have that response
you want to get them in some sort of
Flow State give them a very simple thing
and then right from the start the thing
I do that's pretty unusual compared to
most teachers is from the very beginning
I'm teaching them to put their own
unique presentational Spin Art it is
always ideally do this trick in a way
that no other person would do it exactly
the same way what are you saying how are
you saying it what's your Vibe who are
you
and how are you as you going to do this
trick for whoever you do it for
and the theory is that particularly in a
casual sort of social performance as
opposed to a formal show like you saw I
sort of think that ideally the
performance should be a bit different
every time you should never say exactly
the same thing because the Situation's
different that being present to that
person in that moment and like how to
guide that how to feel that how to keep
it adaptable and keep it real and
everything how long were these courses
that you taught in the small groups the
ones I did back then it was four weeks
four three hour sessions once a week for
for a month and it was pretty good the
there's a bunch of people who I'm still
in touch with who got started there and
that's always very gratifying but I love
the different reasons why people would
do it like there was a bartender who
wanted to get better tips and I'm like
oh cool that's a very different thing to
at school that's a great use case yeah
there was a woman in her 70s who was
developing arthritis and wanted like
something to do with her hands as more
fun occupational therapy great that's a
totally different objective that we'll
teach too very differently there was
certain author who was working on a
novel he was published author legit who
wanted to research for a magician
character and wanted to make sure he
actually understood the source material
and I'm like I respect that good for you
like actually want to know what you're
talking about doesn't matter reveal it
gets the sleight of hand down he just
needs to understand to be present I'm
like this is great these are all
wonderful reasons that we can we can
feed all of these so in my case I would
say that I would like to be able to use
found objects so rather than travel with
a kit yep very relatable right you're
like the dinner with the toothpick and
the silver words like I can do that
anywhere yeah it feels more organic it's
more relatable and it could be I mean
this isn't Magic but like I had a friend
who was incredibly good at turning paper
napkins into like roses and all sorts of
stuff and it was wonderful because it
traveled with him yeah he could do it
anywhere the question I have next I
suppose because you mentioned kind of
lead into this with what you just said
are there any films or books that
relate to Magic in some way that you
like or that magicians like and the
reason I ask is because I'm sure there
are ton that you do not like and
I have one friend who's an extremely
high level professional drummer I loved
the movie Whiplash yeah he can't watch
it though because there are all these
technical aspects that they took a lot
of creative license with so are there
any movies docs books yeah anything
absolutely there's a few because the one
an interesting one because you've got
the to start with the very famous One
The Prestige is interesting because I
would rate its magic accuracy is
extremely low but it's a good movie yeah
I like the movie The Complete a couple
of things it actually gets pretty good
but mostly very like they never kill the
doves in the cages the whole twins think
it's very not representative but good
movie I liked it in terms of magic
accuracy there's a book I would
recommend to anyone a book called hiding
the elephant by Jim steinmeyer which is
the only magic history book I've ever
completely enjoyed I'm not a good
non-fiction reader I need a plot to keep
me going hiding the elephant's amazing
you learn a lot about perception
psychology history Houdini goes into
some of the details really interesting
in a good read are you sure Arrested
Development a cult classic sitcom
I remember when it came out in the
Melbourne magic scene we were watching
this show it was just hilarious and
Incredibly written going and there's Joe
Bluth the magician character who plays
this awful awful magician parody
character but it's accurate awful parody
and that's not normally the case like
you but Wonderstone for example it's
again good movie not accurate for magic
like it's this Whimsical silly thing of
fine Joe Bluth whoever wrote this knows
the magic industry like it's two on the
nose like it's kind of like when
musicians talk about spinal tap yeah and
then getting lost backstage yes and not
being able to get through the curtains
yeah this person knew yeah Joe Bluth
arrest development is that for magic
It's so dead on like the gothic Castle
is a perfect parody of the Magic Castle
the alliance of magicians is so in the
same way that the real estate people are
parodies of All For Real Estate tropes
the magic is so accurate in that in this
Twisted Barry way it's so good if it
turns out I think it was Mitch hurwitz
is like a Magic Castle member and knows
the industry I'm like yeah that checks
out so there are a number of docs that
I've watched I've had this maybe
Fascination from a distance with magic
for a long time but I've never jumped
into it I haven't known how in part
because it's so expansive in its scope
I'm like I don't know how to do this
whereas if it's something like a
language it's like okay well let's
figure out what a thousand most
frequently occurring words are let's
figure out the send structure like I
know how to break it down whereas with
magic I'm like ah how do we boil this
ocean I'm not really sure but I have
watched a bunch of docs I really enjoyed
delt which is a fantastic documentary
about Richard Turner who lives near
Austin and San Antonio who lost his
eyesight and uh One of a Kind an amazing
character an incredible card mechanic
also an honest liar about is it the
amazing Randy James Randy yeah James
Randy and that leads into my next
question and here's how it connects so
for people who watch an honest liar
Randy was famous as a magician but he's
also famous and I'm not sure if he's
still around but as a debunker yeah and
he wanted to identify frauds in
charlatans and he actually provided a
real service in a bunch of cases where
there were some very manipulative
cult-like figures who were convincing
people to leave their medications and
donate money and do all these things
that were certainly not in their best
interest
I have noticed at least
among some of the magicians I've had
exposure to who are from either the U.S
UK or Australia that there's a strong
atheistic identity yeah okay very common
right now on one hand I can see why that
would make sense if you feel like you
are able to identify part of your skill
in Magic is deconstructing illusion and
Truth seeking but are there religious
magicians out there there must have been
at some point and the reason that I'm
curious is it almost a prerequisite to
have an atheistic or at the very least
agnostic stance to be accepted by
magicians now yeah if they're from a
sort of secular Western frame the
challenge they absolutely are religious
magicians and much like any demographic
trend it's it's a huge spectrum of
someone who's you know a chill observant
you know Quake or whatever who does
magic all the way up to someone who's an
Evangelical whatever who uses magic in
their sermons and everything in between
and again this is not my area I you know
I'm not really highly qualified to speak
to it but if you ever want a fascinating
Google rabbit hole just Google gospel
magic gospel as a genre and there is a
genre of magic that is you know products
and books and things are released for
about how to use magic with religious
themes to communicate religious Concepts
and it is fascinating without placing
any value judgment either way on that it
is an eye-opening little niche that
exists uh again magic is Broad and deep
there is so much more in there than you
can imagine
jigsaw puzzles yeah how on Earth do we
get to jigsaw puzzles while struggling
to be a professional magician and work
out how to make a living and pay my rent
and afford health care in America and
all those things and struggling really
badly I realized that also it really hit
me that with magic even the best case
you know you become David copfield or
Penn and Teller or whoever Shin Lim
you're crushing it it shows are
successful it hit me that I realized I
don't enjoy doing the same thing day in
day out and it suddenly hit me that even
if I achieved you know quote unquote
success in Magic I still think I
wouldn't be happy
and that was a really confronting
realization yeah totally and also you
know I was reading a lot of you know
passive income is good trying to work
out my long-term financial future how to
like learning more about business Theory
and everything else and basically long
story short someone I knew was thinking
of making some jigsaw puzzles and ran
into the idea that I had been working
completely separately with the
engineering and geometry and math and
programming background on these things
called geometric vanishes the most
famous one is the infinite chocolate
illusion that many people have seen I
haven't seen but I need to look it up
look it up infinite chocolate illusion
it's great you chop up a block of
chocolate and rearrange the pieces and
it looks like you remove a piece but the
block is still intact it's a really
delightful very clever little geometric
illusion I had a bunch of ideas on ways
I could use this a lot of the material I
do starts with me seeing something
that's pretty good and I'm like I think
this could be better I think there's
more here than is being explored that's
where a lot of my things begin and again
I went what is an egg on it I'm like
what is okay let's really let nuts and
went away like as per Jordan's very
accurate story and I'm like what is
going on here let's really get into this
and started like drawing diagrams and
doing mathematical research and reading
the source material and six months later
I found that when I work on things 19
out of 20 of them go nowhere or like
okay but not great and I'm like oh well
that's fine that's just the ratio it
takes to try stuff and this one was like
that I sort of had some ideas but it
never got there but I'd done all the
reverse engineering I I knew what an egg
was in that regard
and then it was the center of like what
if we like just make a product that goes
on shelves and jigsaw puzzles are
popular but at the time they were all
kind of boring you know they would just
get a piece of art whacking on a puzzle
and while we were talking about this we
ran out the idea of like wait a minute
could that geometric vanish be applied
to a jigsaw puzzle I'm like I don't know
but maybe and I went away and didn't
shower for six days and went like fully
into the tank I like went into full you
know creative mode
and realized yeah I think it can there's
a few complicated constraints on how it
would have to happen and how the die
lines would be cut but like I think this
is doable and again long complicated
story Ledger then did some prototypes
and eventually put the puzzles up on
Kickstarter and by absurd coincidence
this happened to be right at the
beginning of the first 2020 pandemic
lockdown so for you guys
good timing probably insane kind of too
good I learned a term apparently that
originates from Xerox a success disaster
where something is so big it causes
problems yeah and it's actually worse
than if it had been small sometimes I
call that the hug of death yeah
completely in so many ways because also
this was
a time where in the pandemic lockdown
Global Supply Chain crisis this was like
before it was cool we were having a
supply chain crisis before the rest of
the world was it was just insane and
dealing with it but the puzzles were
good and I suddenly realized oh my God
this is a thing maybe I don't have to
just want to shoot myself in the face
from trying to be a professional
magician all the time like maybe I can
actually be a product designer and
create beautiful things that bring
people happiness and wonder and joy that
then I just scale and sell and I don't
have to be just like dealing with the
contracts and the negotiation and the
hustling and just the exhausting
dynamics of doing it and it was this
real revelation of realizing that all
the things that I'd learned in software
engineering and in Psychology and in
Magic they're all kind of the same it's
all experience designed to some degree
and it was an amazing exercise to be
able to apply all of that thinking and
realize it absolutely translates across
different fields and applying that to a
jigsaw puzzle to give the same
experience of surprise Wonder delight
and it was a real I hope for me and now
as I think about the future I'm like
okay what else can we apply these
thinking to what is the next thing that
can use this kind of background and
understanding of human experience in
Psychology and engineering and
everything else to make optimize
something else in a surprising way you
have some good friends as far as I can
tell to help with thinking through these
things as well we'll find out you have a
good crew lots of special agents
so that
is the number one back puzzle of all
time it is Kickstarter yeah and I highly
recommend people check this out so I
have not yet received mine but so magic
puzzle company yeah people need to check
out magic
puzzlecompany.com people can find you at
simoncornell.com where would you like
your show to go what is your sort of
Ideal dream
manifestation of that what does it look
like mostly this show began the short
answers I don't know yet I'm going in
there with The Beginner's mind I'm not
sure I've learned that no matter what
you expect I was talking with my good
friend VM vyam Sharma medical doctor and
magician in Melbourne after fism I went
through as I've learned is not uncommon
after massive success I went into a deep
existential depression for about six
months which was a really weird
complicated messy time for all kinds of
reasons one of the many things that
helped me claw out of it was something
actually he said that you can as we see
throughout history all the time you can
have the best plan you can have
everything figured out you know what
you're doing you've got the plan it's
going to be great and then out of
nowhere it can fail or you can also have
no idea what you're doing no idea where
you're going but move forward work hard
be a good person keep your eyes open and
things can just work out out of nowhere
and so it made me kind of feel more okay
that I didn't know where I was going or
what I was doing which is always the
cause of what do I do now how do I make
a living what is going to happen
and so that's kind of where I'm at with
the show right now I don't know but I
want it to I first had the idea for this
show back in 2013 as sort of a full show
version of this idea of take a moment to
preserve it in the world in a wonderful
way and it has never quite hit the full
vision of the vision in my mind of what
it was going to be it's very close now
thanks to Chad and thanks to another
friend Tim who introduced me to Chad and
a few other people that again the team
the wonderful people who've been
involved right now I mostly want to see
it hit the full vision I want to see the
full version of it it's like 90 there
now it's a few more improvements
and just for my own like internal
spiritual satisfaction I want to close
this plot Arc so it took me to the World
Championships I just wanted to end the
story I just wanted to like try the
thing see what happens find the thing
yeah complete the story arc and then I
don't know and then whatever comes next
we'll find out maybe nothing maybe
that'll be it and it'll go nowhere that
often is what happens with these things
maybe it'll go somewhere who knows I
mean sometimes doors closed sometimes
more interesting doors open than we
could have planned for right and From
the Ashes new phoenixes are sometimes
born is there anything else you would
like to say any requests to my audience
anything at all that you'd like to add
before we wrap up this first recorded
conversation how many more hours have
you got
the world's confusing the world's
complicated it's difficult it's hard for
most people it's just really damn hard
but that doesn't mean that it doesn't
have to be great as well I don't know
yeah I'm wary of advice you know yeah
but uh I mean pontificating
it's not necessarily equal prescription
yeah true true that I think I think
that's a good place to wrap try the
puzzles they're delightful I'm trying
the puzzles I'm a person who is
incredibly critical of his own work
every time I watch back a show I'm like
ah you know the audience liked it but
I'm unhappy the puzzles are so good they
just really make me smile with just how
well they turned out it's a beautiful
thing so it's the reason they've been
backed as much as they have been packed
and there's a lot of excitement as
people will see online if they go look
around
magicpuzzlecompany.com check it out
folks and for links to everything we've
talked about you can find them in the
show notes as per usual at tim.blog
podcast thank you Simon my pleasure and
until next time folks be a little Kinder
than as necessary not only to others to
yourself as well and thanks for tuning
in
hey guys this is Tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet Friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bold Friday easy to sign up
easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that I send out every Friday to
share the coolest things I've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles I'm reading books I'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that get sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcasts guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then I test them and then I share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about if
you'd like to try it out just go to
tim.blog slash Friday type that into
your browser Tim dot blog Friday drop in
your email and you'll get the very next
one thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by all
birds it is summer 2023 finally and this
is the summer to explore I'm about to do
that myself and I'm looking at the floor
in front of me literally three feet away
what do I have I have my all birds so
before you set foot out the door set
foot in the ultimate travel shoes from
all birds super comfortable and
sustainable shoes all birds are
versatile enough to go with any outfit
durable enough to wear on any terrain
and lightweight enough to make packing a
breeze plus the tree Dashers Runners
Pipers and other Albert's tree shoes are
made from insanely comfortable Breezy
eucalyptus fiber they're the only shoes
your suitcase needs I am speaking from
experience here I've been wearing all
birds for the last several months and
I've been alternating between two pairs
I'm traveling with them right now I
started with the tree runners in Marine
blue in case you're curious and now I'm
wearing the tree Dashers and the tree
Dashers are my current daily driver I
wear them for everything they're easy to
slip on easy to tie everything is about
them is just easy easy simple simple I
stick with the blue hues and the Dashers
in this case are in buoyant blue the
colourpops I've received a ton of
compliments but putting the color aside
the tree Dasher is an everyday running
and walking shoe that's also great for
light workouts super comfortable and
I've been testing it on long walks in
Austin I've also been testing it on the
trails and Pavement in places like New
Zealand get in vacation mode before you
even leave the house with all birds find
your perfect pair at allbirds.com today
and use code Tim that's Tim for free
socks just add them to your shopping
cart with a purchase of 48 or more
that's all birds
a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s.com and code Tim Tia
check
this episode is brought to you by
Aeropress I love Aeropress with more
than 45
000 5 Star reviews and customers in more
than 60 countries it might be the
highest rated coffee maker on the planet
let's rewind just a bit because back in
2010 2011 I tested the entire gamut of
coffee brewing and filtering options
alongside a former Barista world
champion this was for research for the
four hour Chef that concluded with a
statement that the Aeropress was quote
Bar None my favorite Brewing method end
quote I even mentioned it and made a cup
of coffee on Late Night with Jimmy
Fallon using the Aeropress here is the
back back story remember the aerobi the
amazing ufo-like disc that you could
throw farther than a football field
Allen Adler a mechanical engineer and
Stanford University lecturer created
that then after Conquering the 1980s toy
Market he began to obsess over one thing
coffee the result was the Aeropress
which debuted in 2006 it was quickly
adopted by the specialty coffee
community and it became so popular with
the Barista community that someone in
Oslo Norway started a world Aeropress
Championship because the Aeropress
combines the best of three Brewing
methods you get a cup that is
full-bodied like a French press smooth
and complex as if you were using a pour
over method and rich in flavor like
espresso best of all it's super small
you can pack it in your bag when you
travel it takes literally five seconds
to clean it is all practical no fuss and
you don't have to drink mediocre coffee
at your office or Airbnb now they have a
new extra large version called XL that
serves two times as much coffee as the
original Aeropress pick one up at
aeropress.com Tim for a fraction of the
cost of a fancy machine that's
a-e-r-o-p-r-e-s-s.com slash Tim and my
listeners that you guys can get 15 off
just use the link aeropress.com Tim one
more time that's aeropress.com Tim
[Applause]